Guys, I have a problem at work.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry I'm late.
I have a problem.
You know, what's the worst part?
The worst part is that I was fine.
I would not have played Overwatch.
But I got faded.
I was working, you see.
I was working.
And then one of my friends messaged me at like 1 in the morning.
And was like, hey, you want to play a couple of Overwatch games?
And I was like, okay.
So...
It's a duo.
It's a couple.
It should be fine.
And then they were like, oh, sorry.
And then we played one game.
We played one game.
And they were like, oh, sorry.
I got to go.
I was like, no.
No, I was so close.
So I was like, you know what?
The season just started.
It can't be that bad.
.
The season just started.
It can't be that bad.
Solo queueing.
You know?
And I was like, I'm just going to solo queue.
And it can't be that bad.
The season just started.
And I was like, I won.
I won.
Oh, my God.
Maybe I can solo queue to the Masters right now.
And then I kept winning.
And then I lost.
But then I was like, oh, no, I can't end on a loss.
And then I was winning again.
I was like, oh, I might as well just go to bed until I get Masters at this point if I'm still winning.
And then it was 6 in the morning.
Six in the morning.
And I was like...
Oh no.
I have a problem.
You know...
You know what's the worst part about that?
One of my friends actually told me like...
I think we do need an intervention.
They're like...
I think you need rehab.
And I was like...
No.
I'll be okay.
I was like... It was like six in the morning.
I was like...
No.
I'll be okay.
It's not that bad.
And I realized...
Oh wait.
I don't really have a thumbnail yet.
And I was like...
Wait.
I need to do a little bit of work first.
And I went to bed at like...
Seven in the morning.
And then I was like... No.
I'll be okay.
That's like eight, nine, ten, eleven...
That's like five hours of sleep.
I'll be okay.
And then I realized... Wait.
I have to walk dad.
Because if I sleep now...
At six in the morning...
I wouldn't have enough...
I wouldn't be able to walk him in time.
So I was like... Okay.
I'll go walk.
I'll go walk dad.
Before I head to bed.
And feed him.
I played for so long.
That it was eating time.
And I was like... No.
I don't have a problem.
To my friend.
I was like...
That's enough sleep.
And I woke up today.
And I messaged my friend.
And I was like... I think I have a problem.
I'm so fucking tired.
I was like...
Why didn't anyone stop me?
And my friend was like...
We tried.
But...
You were the one.
That decided to solo queue.
Overwatch.
I was like... Okay.
I need to show you guys.
I know you guys are like... Oh my god.
Doki.
I thought this was...
I need to show you.
One of my games.
Because they got played.
My master rank up game.
Was at...
My...
My master's rank up game.
Was actually...
So fucking crazy.
Because...
There was a player on...
My team.
And like...
He ended up getting 30k damage.
And I was like...
My Ashe is so good.
And then...
It should have been a red card.
Because like...
It should have been like a red flag to me.
Because the second most damage...
Um...
In both DPS teams...
Is...
12k.
So it was like 12k versus 30k.
And all I could...
It was 6 in the morning chat.
It was...
I was like...
Whoa.
He's so good at this game.
And then...
But like...
Nobody said anything.
That's the thing.
Not my team.
Not the enemy team.
No one said anything.
So I was just like...
This is just 6am queues.
In my head I was just like...
This could just be 6am queues.
And...
I just got a really good...
Really really good player who's like...
Smurfing or some shit.
Because he had good game mechanics.
Like he was like dodging bullets.
And like he was like using his gun.
Okay it should have been red flag.
When he like...
He like... He got... I nanoed him twice.
Because I was like...
Wait he is actually really good.
So I nanoed him.
And in the moment he got nanoed.
He just went into 1v5.
He literally got off high ground.
And just stood in front of everybody.
And then killed 3 people.
But then all I could think about was like...
Damn that nano was sick.
I was like...
Wow.
Because he had a mercy pocket.
The mercy was not healing anybody.
Barely healed anybody else.
And...
And so I was just like...
Okay obviously they are a duo.
Because she was literally just standing there.
Legitimately just standing there.
Not moving.
Not even doing any mercy movement.
She just stood next to him.
And that's it.
And I was just like...
Wow.
They are clearly duo.
I don't know.
I was tired.
Okay I need to show you guys.
No it's okay.
I really need to show you guys.
His gameplay.
Because the moment I saw his gameplay.
I was like...
Wow.
Alright so...
So...
Guess which one is the hacker.
Hahahaha.
He is so good.
This is my rank up game.
Okay.
I need to show you guys this.
Hahahaha.
It was so funny.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's see.
Where is the...
Oh yeah I had Coldbreaker on my team.
No even he didn't say anything.
Nobody said anything.
I'm so fucking confused.
Look.
Look at this.
It is actually crazy.
I need you guys to look at this.
Hahahaha.
He is so good.
He is so...
Alright.
Nobody said anything.
Like what is that?
Like...
Hahahaha.
Holy shit.
What the fuck.
I didn't...
Okay.
I didn't know.
I didn't fucking know.
No.
No one said shit.
Hahahaha.
No one...
No one said anything.
Hahahaha.
Oh yeah.
No I need...
If I give you guys like the POTG.
Okay and then I nattoed him again.
I nattoed him twice.
Okay.
I didn't know.
Like how was I supposed to know.
Like what.
What is this?
It is crazy.
Like he just go...
Bum.
Oh my god.
I want to know which one was play of the game.
The...
The play of the game was insane.
Yeah this.
I think this was the play of the game.
Like...
Hahahaha.
Like what was that?
Holy shit.
He doesn't hesitate.
Hahahaha.
Oh my god.
The flicks are crazy.
Okay.
Yeah.
I was just like.
Oops.
Hahahaha.
Alright anyway.
Let's play Wukong.
Sorry I had to.
I had to show you guys that.
I was just.
The play of the game was even more blatant.
So.
I was just like.
Bum.
And I was like.
What the fuck?
I was just like.
Oh my god.
I was tired.
And like.
No one else said anything.
The enemy team was like.
That's a hacker.
And I would be like.
Oh shit he's hacking.
Alright.
Like I won't nano him.
I just thought he was really good.
I literally thought he was just.
Really really good.
Oh.
Anyway.
Anyway it's Wukong time.
Hahahaha.
Hmm.
Oh my god.
Everyone was just.
Everyone was like.
Six in the morning.
It's like a.
A decent play.
Oh my god.
He didn't even.
Yeah he didn't even pretend not to.
I think he had like a trigger bot.
Cause like what.
It was so fast.
I was like oh my god.
Like that is so.
I was like that's not inhumane.
Like every time.
It was like.
Bum.
I don't know which section was play the game.
But I saw they played a game and I was like what the fuck was I watching?
Hahaha.
Oh no.
He just has a really good game chair.
You better yup it's not.
By popular vote.
You guys want Chinese speech I wish you could turn the text bigger.
I wish you could turn the text bigger.
My only concern about this game is that the text is so fucking small.
I hate it.
I really wish the text was just a li- if it's a little bit bigger, it would've been like, fine.
But, um...
No.
No, you can't.
You can only turn on subtitles, turn on colorblind, and then like, turn off motion blur for accessibility.
And then for these, it's just like, you know, text, speech, subtitles.
Um...
Um, yeah, we all gotta read.
The people demand it!
Oh!
Okay.
Wait, okay.
Somebody gave, like, a really good idea.
But then the thing is, if I do it, it might look really off.
Okay, wait, I have a really good idea.
Let me- let me see if I can- alright, give me a sec.
Alright, copy.
Paste.
Ooh, now you don't see me.
I actually like that idea.
Someone was like, just- just magnify the text.
I was like, wait, that's actually- that's actually smart.
That's actually so smart, but it's gonna look so fucking weird.
But we'll see.
We'll see.
He just needs to talk.
Alright.
I don't know what sound guy is here, but, like, I adjusted the volume just a little bit more.
Because I know, like, the Chinese speech is a little bit more quiet.
It's a bit quiet- more quiet than, uh, than the English dub.
Oh!
No, you're not late.
I had a- I had a 17 minute rant about Overwatch.
Okay.
Alright.
Monkey.
I like it.
Okay, we're monkeying.
Have I- do I have all the upgrades on?
I don't even remember what I did.
Alright, uh... set brew.
Okay, yeah, I do.
Alright.
I should have everything, right?
I have to make sure.
I gotta double check.
My brain is still waking up, guys.
Uh...
It's not the one I'm using?
Wait, what is this?
Oh!
Oh, these are my items that I've never used.
Oops.
Oh, I have other- oh.
That's awkward.
It's pretty awkward.
Oh, that's, like, consumable.
Oh, yeah, I was saving- um...
Guys, you can't- you don't understand.
This gourd?
I only have one use, guys.
You don't understand.
I can't use it.
Guys, I have one use.
If I use it, I don't have it anymore.
Guys, you don't understand.
It's- it's very important to me.
Okay, let's see.
Did I craft- did I craft- did I use my two silk yet?
It's for the final boss.
Exactly.
Chat, it's for the final boss.
Guys.
Oh, yeah, I forgot.
Like, when you're a monkey, I don't know where to go.
Oh, I found it.
Guys, I found it.
Nice.
All right.
I know where to go now.
Nice.
Yasmin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, shit!
Oh, my God.
What the-
How strong are their arrows?
Why are the rats stronger than the wolves?
They're smiling.
How are the rats stronger?
What the fuck are the wolves doing?
How the fuck do I get up there?
Where actually how the fuck do I get up there?
This is bullshit.
This is actually bullshit.
If I can't get up there, I'm going to open your door.
You can't open the door, guys.
It doesn't let me open the door.
Wait, how the fuck do I get in?
How the fuck do I get in?
Oh shit!
It's okay.
You can't get me now.
I have a roof.
That's fucking right.
I have a fucking roof.
What you gonna do now?
Okay.
Have you tried the door?
Hello?
Knock knock?
Please open this door, sir.
I swear, I'm not dangerous.
Like, yes, there's a dead body out there.
But that wasn't me.
That wasn't me.
That dead body.
That could be any...
He was dead before I got here.
Oh, wait.
There's invincibility.
If I...
Did you guys see that?
I didn't get hurt because I was opening the chest.
The chest invincibility.
How the fuck do I...
Do I hit the door?
Open up.
Knock knock.
Guys, open the door.
The man was dead already when I got here.
It wasn't me.
I swear to God.
I did not kill this man.
He just...
He died from a heart attack.
I swear to God.
I swear he died from a heart attack.
Alright.
Oh.
Guarded the gate?
Oh, shit.
Oh.
Alright.
Oh, shit.
Wait.
That's...
Yes.
They know magic?
Fucking rats.
Alright.
I'm gonna kill this rat.
That's right.
What's your magic gonna do?
Against my... Oh.
That.
That's right.
But what's your magic gonna do?
Now.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
But like...
But like... Okay.
Now.
You can't do jack shit.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Guys, his magic is pretty strong.
Guys.
Oh, my...
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Guys.
Guys, his... his baby's here too.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Why are these rats so strong?
What the fuck were the wolves doing?
Like, what...
What were the wolves fucking doing?
So, like, I saw the text worked.
Okay.
So... Oh, shit.
I... Never mind.
It's so fucking weird.
Okay.
It's okay.
Bye.
I will use baby if I have to.
Alright.
Nice.
Rat dead.
That's the least of my worries.
Oh, hey.
Turtle!
Hello, turtle.
Why...
What the fuck is this level scaling?
The powers.
Oh, shit.
Oh, shit!
Does he have two heads?
What the fuck?
You fucking freak!
Okay.
Even your mother doesn't love you.
Look at you.
Your mother didn't even give you fucking clothes.
Oh, my god.
Oh, and then, you know what?
Let's give you...
Okay.
I don't think I like Sad Land.
I...
Holy shit.
Oh, my god.
Guys.
I'm gonna fuck this.
Just for this one rat guy.
Just for him.
I will...
use my power up.
Jesus Christ!
Oh, my god!
This isn't even a baby!
That's the worst part!
He's just a regular guy!
Okay.
A regular guy with two heads, but still.
Aw, fuck this.
That's fucking right.
I have fire repellent now.
Can't be jack shit.
I don't care about you I messed up every single of my utilities and all my HP.
Oh, my god.
This is a lesser Yao Guai, too.
He's a rat captain!
Upon side by side.
Oh, my god.
And he still breathes fire!
Oh, shit!
Alright.
Now I know.
Now I fucking know.
Okay.
This is awkward because now I have no HP.
Oh, these are like shortcuts!
I have to open on the other side.
Oh, no, no.
That's not a shortcut.
That's...
What's wrong with this guy?
That's his dad?
Who did he bang?
He's here!
Go away!
I don't know...
This is a secret or something.
WHAT IS THIS?
I think it's a secret.
So far...
Modern solutions.
Modern problems require modern solutions.
That's me!
Oh
shit!
Um...
Wait!
What if I just walk...
Oh no...
I have accepted my fate.
How did you hurt yourself?
I'm standing still!
He fucking hurt himself!
How did that happen?
I needed to fucking...
Guys, I don't have heals!
I don't have magic!
I needed to die there!
There was no way!
I had to die there so I could...
Fuckin' reset everything.
Alright, let's see.
I need to figure out how to get back there.
Should be this way.
Okay, I don't really care.
I'm just gonna run past everything.
Also, is the volume up better?
I know, like, the Chinese dub is, like, a little bit quieter than the English dub.
Alright, there you go.
I have zero heals, guys!
I wasted it all.
I'm gonna get the... the dad.
Okay, I'm not gonna...
Oh, shit!
I'm sorry, I won't fuckin' kill your dad.
I'm sorry.
Baby.
And then...
Boom!
That's fuckin' right.
Fire!
I forgot how to play this game.
This is not good.
How am I...
Oh, it's cuz...
It's cuz of the dad.
What if I'm just...
Where's the dad?
Where the fuck did the little guy go?
Wait, I hear him.
What?
Where is he?
I...
Okay.
He's, like, super slow.
His moveset is, like, incredibly slow.
Alright.
Where... Where is the little guy?
Okay.
Alright, that's...
Oh!
I don't even know what you're doing!
He's got a K Pain.
How do you even know he's your dad?
I mean, look at you two.
All I'm saying is if you look at these two together, like I don't know.
I wanna know how to fuck those two.
He was able to do that.
And get that.
Okay.
Death Throwing Rocks is literally self defense.
FRIENDS!
Oh god.
Okay.
Come on.
Come on!
Bro!
Stop!
Oh god.
I need a fucking...
Oh there he is!
He's so tiny!
It's so hard to see!
Oh shit!
The worst part is that it's so tiny that I can't even fucking see!
Oh my god.
You have...
Now I know why you were like this.
Jesus!
Oh my god!
Please!
Have mercy!
Are you serious?!
That hit me?!
Okay.
That's fucked.
That's actually fucked.
Oh...
I didn't realize that would hit me.
The dad better be like one hit or some shit.
Like...
How are you so tanky?!
You're just a little guy!
Oh fucking hell.
Oh my god, bro.
Fuck you.
No, I'm getting rid of you.
Your son's not gonna help you now.
Your son is not gonna help you now.
Your son doesn't even know you exist now.
Your son got fucked.
Your son...
Oh
no.
No he ain't...
He...
What?!
Oh!
I should not have killed the fucking father!
I'm so sorry!
Oh shit!
Guys!
Don't kill the dad first!
He does not like it!
Oh my god!
Guys!
Do not kill the dad first!
He...
For some reason he was not happy that his father died.
I...
Alright.
Now we know.
Now we...
It was a good learning experience chat.
Now we fucking know that dad gets angry.
Son gets angry.
Why would he be so angry?
I don't understand.
Oh my god!
What the fuck?
He traveled all the way...
He traveled all the way here.
I wanted to get rid of the subtitle thing because we don't have words yet.
Alright.
Let's go this way.
Alright, here we go.
Yeah, is the volume a lot better now?
I don't think sound guy is awake at this time.
So...
I know I adjusted it a bit more.
Alright.
That's like so fucked.
Yeah, it's just his dad.
No big deal.
Like I don't...
How the hell was I supposed to know?
Dad, it hurts.
Alright.
Oh shit.
Don't worry.
Fire.
Okay.
You know what?
Maybe no fire.
Alright, son!
I just wanna say.
Your head issue.
Maybe you should stop using your head.
Maybe you should stop using your head for fucking... Oh my god!
Okay.
Not gonna lie.
A lot of his issues could be solved if he doesn't...
If he doesn't bash his head on the floor.
Like, I don't know.
It seems like a very simple solution.
Oh boy.
Oh my god!
But it's okay.
You don't have to listen to me.
Just listen to your dad!
Oh yeah.
No.
Okay.
It's not okay.
Stop using your head during fights!
Your dad not taught you that!
It would be so...
This is why you have head issues!
This is why your head hurt!
And they also know they're giant fucking rats!
Okay.
Alright.
Don't worry.
Ow.
That is not fair.
Oh shit!
Okay.
I hope the dad doesn't get angry.
Like...
I can't believe I get...
Oh!
Okay.
Oh my god!
I can't...
He's so ungebunga that I can't predict him!
That's the worst part!
He's like...
He has no brain!
He has no strength!
He's literally just...
I walk and then I hit!
I don't know how to deal with him!
He has no brain!
Alright.
Here we go.
Now I know my immobility is like not...
Are you serious?
Okay.
Oh god.
Oh please!
I'm stuck inside him!
I'm actually...
I'm stuck!
Oh my god.
This is actually not fair.
Okay.
Alright.
This dad's gonna fucking do that shit again.
Oh god.
Alright.
Oh.
Oh my god.
What are your patterns?
Please.
No!
Okay.
Oh my god.
No!
I ran into that!
Oh.
Why am I so stupid?
Alright.
Nice!
Oh thank god!
His son is dead!
That's right.
You raised that kid for 20 years and I killed him.
That's fucking right.
I killed your son!
That's 20 years wasted!
There we go.
Nice!
Did I kill both?
I wonder what would happen if I did kill both.
I wonder.
I wonder if we could find his head too.
Oh my god.
I used all my resources there.
He literally had like unga bunga strength.
What?
I'm gonna miss the Scottish accent right after.
Yeah!
There was double lines!
Oh my god.
Sorry.
My voice fucking died there.
Holy shit.
My god.
The rat.
The rat fucked me up man.
Bro.
Oh please.
Why?
I will use this.
I cannot be bothered.
Holy shit.
I can't deal with this right now.
I already got ginseng.
Okay nice.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go.
Where do I go?
There has to be an incense somewhere.
Oh my god.
Where am I?
How is there more?
Oh god.
There's too much sand.
There's too much fucking sand.
Oh.
Turn back.
There's a shrine.
Oh there it is.
Oh thank god.
Thank you.
Thank you fairies.
For finding me the shrine.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
I needed it.
Oh.
Thank god there's a shrine.
I can brew.
What did I get?
I got.
Oh.
Increased damage reduction.
I got.
Oh.
Increased damage reduction.
Yes.
I feel like there's no.
There has not been any use for poison.
Do I have new weapons yet?
No.
It's still that stick.
Okay.
Craft armor.
Oh I didn't craft it yet.
I found four silk.
Okay.
The back wind will attack enemies nearby.
The destined ones and the decoys continuously.
Oh.
The decoys can attack.
Thank god.
I'm getting more of the Wukong strength.
Okay.
Yes.
Okay, now I can make another one.
Uh.
Deals additional damage.
Plus twelve.
Encounter surrounding back attack will attack enemies nearby.
Wait but.
Yeah but that thing already does it.
I already have that that does it.
So, yes, okay.
We should get this one, because we already have that.
Does it stack?
It doesn't say it stacks though.
No set, no three set.
Oh, you need three?
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
I don't have three.
All right.
Oh, that's not fair.
I don't have enough silk.
No!
I don't have enough silk!
I didn't get enough!
Increases after a moment.
God damn it!
It has additional damage to it.
Okay, we got it.
Might as well.
We might as well...
I'm just gonna grab this then.
Do I have enough?
No.
Oh, wait, I do.
Oh my gosh.
Guys.
I'm a little special.
I woke them all back at back seaters.
Oh, I can buy silk!
I can finally buy silk!
Oh my god.
They finally stocked up on silk.
They answered my prayers.
All right, let's rest up.
We finally have enough money to purchase the silk.
All right.
Water...
So for those who don't know the story.
I talked about the story a little bit.
I thought... Originally, I thought the... Oh, shit!
Okay.
Okay, we're gonna... Actually, we're gonna deal with...
We're gonna deal with the arrow guys first.
That's right.
I can come... Wait... Wait... Wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
You mean I can't kill you?
You?
You mean my stick?
How?
What's the point of using a stick if it's not fine?
What do you mean I can't just kill you?
Why is my stick not long enough?
I can't jump!
Wait, I can?
Wait, how jump?
Oh my god.
Guys.
I...
It's a jump buddy?
This game has not taught...
This fucking game has never said anything about the jump buddy.
What?
Now?
Now it tells me that jumping exists.
Are you kidding me?
It never told me about the jump buddy.
Wait, is that the dad?
Hello, I killed your son.
All I'm saying, dad, is that...
Your wife is gone anyway.
Oh shit.
What the fuck is he doing?
Forest Prince?
You have tooth?
How do you manage to fucking get this son?
Bro, who the fuck did you fuck?
He must have good bed game.
Like, what the fuck?
Well.
Alright.
Bye, dad.
He was a terrible father anyway.
Hey guys.
He literally locked up his first son.
Bart Simpson style.
In the basement.
Like, that's not a good dad.
.
That's awkward.
He locked up his fucking son, man.
In the basement.
And then he fed him his own blood?
That's not dad of the year.
Alright, anyway, let's fight him.
Hello!
Baby!
Alright.
Okay, just get this over with.
Just... just punch me.
Just...
I don't think this is the run.
We have to restart here.
I...
I figure after that, a restart was in order.
After that, I think...
I think we had to restart the run.
I don't know how!
How did I miss?
Are you fucking...
Bro, please!
Oh, please, man.
I just...
I just wanna fight the other big baby.
The baby rat.
Let me fight the baby rat.
He has nothing to live for.
He's been a basement rat for his entire life.
He has no education.
He has nothing to live for.
We gotta put him down.
He literally ate his father.
He's a catapult now.
Nobody can fix him.
He's literally a catapult.
Oh, fuck it.
I don't care enough for this.
Alright.
It's time to fight.
It's time to fight the other big baby rat.
Alright, this time.
My very first time fighting him.
I know that's weird that there's no, like, intro or anything, you know?
Like...
This is the first time I see this guy and there's no intro.
I wonder...
It's so weird, guys!
First time fighting him and there's like no intro?
I wonder why.
Oh my god.
I wonder why there's no intro, guys.
Oh, shit.
Alright.
Yeah, I think I got...
I think I experienced my first glitch today, guys.
Oh, shit.
Alright, nice.
I've definitely experienced my first glitch.
I wonder...
Oh, I wonder how he got here.
This random rat in my game.
This lucky random rat in my game.
What's his story?
Oh, man.
I wonder...
He looks just like that other rat I killed.
I guess I'll never know.
Nice.
Oh, no.
My...
He's so low!
Yeah, this random...
Oh, this must be like...
Like those...
It's like Dark Souls.
Like those optional bosses that like...
There's no intro or anything.
It's like...
Holy fuck!
Big Baby was not happy!
Oh, shit.
Okay.
The double dodge.
Oh, god.
Please.
Oh, my god.
He is so tanky.
All right.
I'll do this.
And then...
Oh, no.
I don't have magic anymore, guys.
I don't have magic anymore!
Oh!
And then the double...
No!
He slaps after that!
Okay.
The tail.
Come on!
Yes!
Easy!
Oh, my god.
First try!
We finally destroyed the bloodline.
That's right.
There's no way.
He couldn't even comprehend what the fuck was going on.
There's no way he made children.
There's no break his knees.
All right.
The royal family of flowering sands.
A foolish son.
A clever father.
One plan went ahead.
The other, rather.
On the battlefield, no room for kin.
The father flees, leaving his son within.
Favored by the king, was a renowned warrior for his valor in the battles.
He was grat...
But later, a shadow darkened his mind, clouding his reasons, erasing his memories of kin.
Thus, he was hidden away.
Oh!
He used...
What the fuck happened to him?
Two of his...
Two of his sons yet remained?
Oh, shit!
Okay.
So...
Um...
So, there's still one more son.
There's...
There's still...
Is that him?
Which one's the son, and which one's the dad?
I can't even tell!
Is this the son, or is this the...
I mean, he was like...
I feel like this is the dad.
This has to be the dad.
Oh my god!
Who did he bring?!
Like, what did he possess to make these children?
No, I think this is...
This is...
This is the father.
We all saw what he looked like.
That sub was like five times his size, guys.
That dad has the most insane riz.
Like...
To be able to...
To be able to, like, produce those sons.
Oh my god.
Alright, let's see.
Well, we killed...
We killed the rat family.
Just one more son left.
I finished the job.
I'm skinny!
I'm failed!
Lord, Jesus Christ.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, Bray.
What is this?
Bless her.
A blaze bone.
On the road, bare bones on display.
Blood shrouded, decayed.
Long gone, forgotten name.
His homeland lost in death's name.
Alright.
Let's see.
God, is there extra loot anywhere?
Oh!
Ugh!
Oh my god, who lives here?
What the fuck?
What did I get?
Oh, I got wine!
Wait, I can upgrade my wine now!
Nice.
Yoink!
Stole your treasure.
Whoever lives here was like, man, although my life fucking sucks, at least I have this wine that cost my entire life savings to buy.
Surely nobody's gonna rob me.
Surely this would be a safe spot and no one will ever find this little hole here and take my entire life savings.
There's no way.
Alright.
Let's go up.
Oh my god, after learning how to jump, everything changed.
Everything changed for me.
Alright.
Hello!
Hello, sir!
You can only shoot once and then that's it.
I learned.
I don't even know if I'm going the correct way anymore.
I...
I don't...
I don't know.
Hello?
What is there?
What's that?
Oh, Batman!
Oh, shit!
Batman's strong!
Who would have thought?
No, it's Man-Bat.
Sorry.
Man-Bat.
Oh my god.
Man-Bat, go back to your billionaire cave!
Okay.
Oh, shit!
No, he slapped me!
Okay.
Nice.
Man-Bat.
Man-Bat down.
The shallow sea, the backwater lies.
Far from clamor under the sky.
In moonlight, hues, blood it sips.
Through yellow wind, it slips.
Alright.
The rent is heavy.
Oh my god, they have to pay rent?
Bro.
The rent is heavy.
Burden on us.
Is there any pos...
No!
Man-Bat has to pay rent!
Not even caves are safe from real estate?
That's fucked.
Oh my.
Too real.
Poor Man-Bat.
He has to pay rent even in this god awful cave that he lives in.
Damn.
Not even in ancient China are you safe from rent.
Oh, shit.
Is that Man-Bat's soul?
Why the fuck would I use Man-Bat?
I have the baby.
Oh, it is.
It is Man-Bat.
How much square feet is that?
I mean, seems like it has a nice view.
Look.
You get to look out into the...
Oh my god, there's an outside backyard.
That seems so bad.
There's an outside backyard.
Can't be that bad.
Wait, then what's this?
Is this like another secret tunnel?
Secret tunnel.
Oh my god.
This is...
How is this... Oh no.
There's more Man-Bats.
How is there so many bats?
Where do I go?
Twelve... This is like twelve million dollars.
This is actually like an exclusive place in... Oh, Crouching Tiger Temple.
This is an exclusive place in New York City.
It's called the Cave Experience.
And it actually goes for like fifty million dollars.
That's actually a steal.
It actually goes for like five hundred million dollars.
Because it is like a gated community within the cave system.
And each little crevice you get, it's like an experience.
You know?
It's very immersive.
It's like insight into like back to the prehistoric times.
So you get to live like how your ancestors did in the past.
It's called experience, guys.
You know how like Airbnbs have those things now where at Airbnbs there's like there's like those special Airbnbs.
I know like there's one where they made it like Edna modes from the Incredibles.
There's like one where you can rent out Edna modes mansion and then they decorate it as if it's like the Incredibles and everything.
And so like you can actually rent out like some like experience Airbnbs.
Yeah!
There is!
You guys didn't know?
Alright, sorry.
Okay, Airbnbs unique, unique I was watching like there was like a video about it.
Um...
and it's like basically like unique Airbnbs.
Okay, cool cool unique Airbnbs world.
They have the most unique Airbnbs.
There's one where you get to sleep in the tower above the sea.
Like you sleep like there's like a house above the sea and you can like live there for a night.
And there's an igloo one too.
I think there's one that was like based off of like the Marvel Universe.
Oh yeah!
There's like, there's a bunker.
You can literally rent out an Airbnb apocalyptic bunker for $700 a night.
Like you can It's like what the fuck?
You can like sleep at a fucking bunker.
Like
There's like some really cool ones.
I was like what the fuck?
Wait I need an Alright.
Tucked away design.
Yeah!
And you can design an incredible.
Look at this.
You can actually design like an incredible super suit there too.
So like I think they like give you an incredible super suit right after.
From there.
Tucked away.
Closed behind gates.
Like that's so fucking insane.
Like You can go What?
You can rent out Wait!
Oh my god!
You can rent out the house from up as an Airbnb Oh!
From May Oh guys you can't anymore.
May to June.
Yeah but like for some special days.
It actually I thought that was actually crazy.
Yeah it's actually real.
I saw a video of the end of mode one.
Um But yeah they have some crazy Airbnbs listed there.
I didn't realize you can actually rent out like Airbnb experiences.
Yeah!
The house from up!
What do you mean house from up?
It's a cartoon!
They literally made the house from up with the balloons and everything as an Airbnb.
You must have signed some.
Also like knowing Disney.
Like I don't know if you should sign those waivers though.
Because that seems like an insane safety concern.
Like knowing Disney.
Those waivers must be insane.
Those safety waivers must be not very good.
So I don't think you should sign.
It looks cool.
But like I don't think you should sign any fucking safety waivers from Disney for a while.
Or like any TOS from them.
You know they took that out?
They finally took it out because of the controversy.
I can't believe they put that in.
It blew my mind that they actually put that.
Oh my god!
Wait there's little rats!
What's the difference between the little rats and the big rats?
Oh shit!
He slapped me!
They bow slapped me!
Fight him!
Fight!
Are they fighting him?
I can't tell if they are!
Oh god.
Okay.
I actually have to use my magic because there's so many bats.
And I don't trust myself with all these bats.
With all these man bats.
Alright let's see.
Is that it?
They were guarding?
These better be some fucking good ass mushrooms.
They're guarding this.
Oh no!
There it is!
That's what they were actually guarding.
Alright.
That's right.
Maybe I'm the bad guy.
Could I be the bad guy and stealing their life savings?
No.
They're bad people so I'm allowed to do this.
Maybe that was self defense.
Because clearly I'm like a home invader, right?
No.
I must have killed thousands of people.
I'm doing a good thing.
I'm the neighborhood watch.
This is self defense.
I might have been invading their home.
But this is self defense guys.
To be fair.
To be fair, Shroom Hong is not a very good person.
Well to be fair, he's a monkey.
He doesn't need a follow rules.
He's a fucking monkey.
He doesn't need to follow any rules made by humans and gods.
He's not a very good monkey.
He's a murder monkey.
He's basically like Kratos but like monkey.
And like he's doing it more so for fun.
Less so for like revenge.
Because he's always been an asshole.
He's always.
I mean he did have like his redemption arc and journey to the west afterwards.
But like he started out as an asshole.
He's He's just been born an asshole.
He just enjoys it.
Alright.
Let's see.
Nice.
Come on.
What is this?
Can I steal that too?
No.
Oh it's a Buddha's offering.
But a monkey.
A monkey.
Alright.
Guys.
Do you think the staircase filled with blood means that there's something bad up ahead?
No.
It's just Halloween.
Maybe it's just close to Halloween guys.
Haha.
Oh my meditating again?
Where is the third son?
I killed so many rat babies too.
I must kill the third to end the bloodline.
Where is he?
Would my bloodlust ever be satisfied?
Oh I keep living and killing babies from different species.
When will monkey find love?
Oh hey, sparks!
Alright.
Nice.
Okay, more stuff.
Look, he's just acting out.
He's lonely.
He's acting out.
He has no, he has no girl, no girl monkey in his life.
He's so lonely.
When will monkey find love?
What about y'all, those human girlfriends?
It's not the same.
They don't know how to do that monkey thing.
Okay, we are great.
Upgrade our guy.
Alright, let's see.
Let's see.
This one ain't even Wukong.
I feel like he must be like a clone or something.
You know, like a hair strand of Wukong or like, I feel like he could be like one of the hair strands because that's happened before.
In the, in the Wukong like adaptations and storylines where like one of his like, hair, hair, hairline like, um, like diverged and created his own life or something.
I should upgrade my stances.
I feel like I don't.
Each hand, oh wait, upon a charge attack, we should have that.
And then...
I feel like it could be either his hair or like a descent, like one of his son's sons or something.
Because like, I'm pretty sure fucking he banged.
I'm pretty sure there's no way.
Yeah, Wukong had a lot of Riz.
All right, let's see.
I feel... oh, nope.
What do I upgrade?
Increases critical hit.
The four banes effect.
Maybe I should... I don't feel like stamina is an issue for me.
I feel like it's more so maybe just get more damage or something.
Upgrade your dodge.
Let's see.
Increase charge.
Oh, I get the thrust.
Is the thrust better?
All right, guys.
Now that it's been a day, clearly I should have had people... people can backseat me now.
Clearly.
Wait.
I do like the smash stance.
I feel like... is the thrust better than the smash?
Thrusting is good.
Now that we all had, like, a day to process this game, the meta must have been developed already.
Like... Okay, thrust stance is good.
Allows to charge upon releasing.
All right, let's try the thrust.
See what that's like.
Okay.
Okay, that's not it.
I just realized I used the wrong one.
All right.
Okay,
that's thrust.
Okay.
All right, that's thrust.
All right, we figured it out.
Oh, hey, there's a togger.
Is he drinking blood?
Blood?
What are you talking about?
Bleedy hell.
Hahaha!
Guys, I don't think he... I think this tiger's British.
Oh, my God!
It's the cat!
I'm gonna kick the cat!!!
Oh, my God!
We're gonna get the trifecta!!!
How Ahaha Oh E slap!
We're gonna grab the trifecta, guys!
We're finally gonna punch the cat!
This is what we wanted!
Finally!
From baby to dark, the cat!
Will anybody stop her?
Nobody can stop me now!
That's fucking right!
Yeah, I punched the cat!
Come on, get over here!
That's fucking right, get over here!
Boom!
Oh shit!
Nice!
Oh, I'm sorry!
Oh!
That's a wrestling cat!
Why do they all wrestle?
Okay, no, he's just punching me.
No, that's just martial arts.
Wait, what?
What the fuck?
He has tornado powers?
He also can use the wind?
Oh god.
Oh, dodge!
Oh shit!
Dodge!
Alright, nice, I dodged.
Freeze!
That's fucking right.
That is so fucked!
Come on!
That is so not fair!
What the fuck?
Why did you get to...
No, no, no, no, no!
No, no, no!
No!
Okay.
Oh my god!
I'm only halfway?
Oh, no.
Oh my god, I'm only halfway.
I'm alread- I don't even have- Oh!
I don't even have my... any more magic.
What do you mean I'm only halfway?
I hate you.
I fucking hate you.
Are you fucking... I hate you.
I hate you so much.
Boom.
That's fucking right.
Don't touch me.
Oh no.
This guy is harder than Big Baby.
It's harder than Big Baby.
I only got halfway.
This guy has... Who is he?
I just want to finish the trifecta.
Wait until you meet him.
There's more.
Oh my god.
Oh, I already looted that.
I already... Oh my god.
Bro, this is what happened to Tony the Tiger after he retired?
After he retired.
This is him now.
Oh, that's not fair.
Do you feel old yet?
This is what happened to Tony the Tiger.
Alright, alright.
After he retired from being Vtuber he needed to do this to...
to lay out there.
Jesus.
Oh my god.
What?!
And you remember like when he does that?
Oh my god.
Please.
Frosted Flakes are great!
He realized... Oh no, this is why we feed him Frosted Flakes.
If he knows...
If he realized that someone gave Tony the tiger!
He was raised up to be a vegetarian!
But then he realized what meat actually tastes like!
Oh no!
This is why we don't feed Tony the tiger real meat!
Guys, we fucked up!
We introduced Tony to real meat!
Oh god.
Okay.
There you go.
That's fucking right.
Nice.
Alright.
Oh, I just dodged a tap.
Oh god!
Again!
Oh shit!
Okay.
Okay, nice.
There you go.
Oh god, here you go.
Alright, nice.
Bye.
Oh shit!
He got me!
No!
I'm trying to remember his stances, but it's so... Oh shit!
He just punches back!
Oh no!
I'm dead!
I'm so classed!
I'm slowly figuring out his stances!
Boy, it's hard!
Bro, he...
He's not supposed to punch back!
He just slacked me like a fly!
He's like, get away monkey!
Oh my god.
I'm sorry, Tony the tiger.
Guys, this is why we don't...
This is why we don't feed Tony meat!
We kept it on a strict vegetarian diet his entire life!
And now he knows!
He knows what he missed out!
Now he's...
Now he's angry!
Hiya!
Boom.
Oh god.
That's fucking right.
Boom!
You didn't expect that, did ya?
Oh shit!
He did a little dance there.
Boom!
Alright, there you go.
Poke!
Alright.
I know that stance.
Nice.
Oh shit, I forgot the second... the third attack!
Poke!
Oh!
Alright, nice.
The hard part is just remembering all his move combos.
He has too many moves!
Ah!
Fuck!
Okay.
I need to hydrate.
Remember to stay hydrated!
Remember to stay hydrated, everybody!
Okay.
Oh!
Fuck!
Okay.
Nice.
Not nice.
Poke!
I can do that again.
Oh!
Fuck!
I'm sorry!
I'm so sorry!
Oh!
What?!
I can't believe it!
I did so well!
How did I time it wrong?!
No.
No way!
What is that?!
I was doing so well!
Oh my gosh!
I hate that when he gets on the stone, the stone part, like, the lock on stops.
It's not fair!
Stupid-ass clone!
Cloning is like a monkey thing!
How dare you!
Cloning is for monkeys only!
It's not fair!
Alright.
Oh, he moves so fucking fast.
Jesus Christ.
This is exa... Oh!
Fuck!
There we go.
No!
I fucked it up!
Oh no!
I hope that is one move.
Okay.
Alright.
I need like...
Okay.
Alright.
Just need to know that.
Okay, I need to regenerate stamina.
Regen... Poke?
Poke.
Get closer so I can poke.
Poke!
Nice.
Alright.
Okay.
No!
Oh!
Smack you in the ass!
Wait, I forgot to use baby!
Almost forgot big baby mode!
Alright.
Nice.
Oh my god.
I can't believe I almost forgot big baby mode!
Okay.
There you go.
I got that dodge correctly.
Okay.
Nice.
There we go.
Jesus Christ.
No!
I saw it too!
I saw it!
I am out of my groove!
I fucked with my groove!
No!
I was doing so well too!
I fucked with my groove!
Oh no.
No!
I can't get the timing!
Actually, that one clone move messed me up so bad!
Why is she hitting the decoy?
It's cuz like...
It's cuz like, if I hit the decoy at the right time, he just does that one punch, which I can dodge.
I can dodge that punch.
Like, before he like, runs away.
But like, if I get the timing off, then like, I'm fucked.
If I get the timing off, it's like, everything's fucked.
It's over.
God, please.
How?
Wait, what?
Wait, my fucking...
Big baby!
I got it down in time.
Oh!
Okay.
Missed.
Haha, you missed, loser.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry for calling you a loser.
I'm sorry.
No!
He got stuck in the wall!
Ah!
Every time!
Okay.
Come on, get closer.
You know you want to.
Come on.
That's right.
That's fucking right.
Bam!
Oh god.
Oh.
No!
Fuck!
I need to time that when he does the jump!
No.
I can't!
Why must you jump?
Boom.
No!
Okay.
Guys.
Tony the Tiger.
Is too strong.
Stop teaching Tony the Tiger martial arts!
See?
Like when he does that I can dodge it.
Very easily.
Aww.
But I can't dodge that.
Boom.
Alright.
I can dodge this at least.
Guys.
I don't think this is it.
I don't think this is the run.
This is not the run.
Guys.
Okay.
Guys, I'm not even halfway and I don't have HP anymore.
I don't even have HP.
No!
Okay.
Please,
Tony.
We're worried about you, Tony!
No!
I dodged it!
This is the first time I've ever dodged it!
No!
It's not fair!
I was in the air!
I've never dodged it before!
Guys, I'm so happy that, like, I did all of that and I'm dead.
He's kicking my ass!
He's actually kicking my ass!
Oh my god, I was supposed to kick the cat, but the cat's kicking me!
Oh, Tony the ass-kicker!
Tony, please!
We need you back on cereal!
Tony, they're great!
Tony, please!
We need you back on the cereal!
Tony!
We can't have you representing me!
What would the children think?
Think, baby!
Okay.
There we go.
See?
If I get him instantly, it's so much easier to dodge!
Got it!
Jesus!
Okay.
Here we go!
Go!
That was on me!
I deserve that!
I 100% deserve that!
I don't know why I thought I could cancel it!
I got a little too cocky there!
I was like, oh, but what if I cancel that?
What?!
How did his break mine?
Oh, no.
Okay.
Alright.
The very first time.
Okay.
Alright.
No!
I tied!
Okay.
Alright.
Nice.
No, he has the second punch!
Alright.
Where is... What?!
Okay.
That wasn't fair.
That was not fair.
Oh my god!
Why?!
Why are you like this?!
Who gave a tiger a sword?!
Here he is!
He has all the advantages in the world!
Why did you give him more?!
What?!
I don't understand!
He already has everything!
Why even a sword?!
Oh, no.
Okay.
Guys, look at my HP.
I don't...
It's over.
Why win when you can win more?
After six and a half hours!
Wait!
Cactus won!
It's too late!
I saw it!
What do you mean?
After six...
I saw it!
It's too late!
I fucking saw it!
Oh my god.
What do you mean upgrade my weapon?
How the fuck do I upgrade my weapon?
The power of frosty flakes.
I can't...
I saw it!
Oh my god.
I can't upgrade shit!
What do you mean?
Am I under level?
Am I fucking under level?
Did I fucking freeze through this too fast?
There is no new stat!
What do you mean?
Alright.
Honestly, if I'm under level, it makes sense.
I will not be surprised if I was under level.
Not gonna lie.
I will not be surprised.
That's for sure.
Alright.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright.
Come on.
You gotta get close to me, right?
Boom!
That's fucking right.
Alright.
Oh!
The third flash!
No!
The first flash!
Oh god.
Oh no!
My groove!
Bam!
That's fucking right.
Oh shit!
Okay.
Thank god.
I dodged that.
Oh!
I dodged that!
Come on.
Oh, thank you.
Whoa!
No!
Oh god.
Okay.
That's fine.
No.
No!
That's not fine.
He's in my corner!
He got me in the corner!
It's not fine in the end.
It was not fine.
Oh no!
I deserve that.
Oh!
I 100% deserve that.
Okay.
No.
Oh!
I dodged it!
I got it!
Fair!
Next time I'm gonna give him...
Okay.
Oh!
Please!
Oh thank god he didn't give him a gun.
I'm glad he didn't get a gun.
No!
I might as well give him a gun!
Even better!
Yeah!
Oh my god!
They might as well!
They might as well give him a fucking gun!
Oh my god!
Oh!
How do I upgrade my staff?
I don't think I saw anything that allowed me to upgrade my staff.
Wait.
Where do you upgrade it?
I'm sorry for never eating my Syria!
Oh it's in the craft?
This one?
But like that's just a normal staff.
I only have that.
You're telling me I can't...
Are you fucking serious?
Are you fucking kidding me?
God I hate everything.
I'm so sad.
I couldn't...
I had a stronger staff!
I...
Okay.
Alright.
Okay Tony.
I'm...
I'm coming back Tony!
That's a little awkward.
Holy shit!
I'm so fucking...
mad!
I'm so mad!
I got...
Guys I couldn't help it!
The fucking Peta wins!
The Peta winning got me!
You don't understand!
The Peta wins!
It was the Peta wins!
Oh my god!
The Peta wins!
Okay.
What that hit me?!
Oh fuck okay.
What?!
Okay!
How did I become worse after getting a better upgrade?!
How did I become...
Oh my god!
I...
I upgraded and it threw off every saw in my pattern.
After upgrading I don't know how to play this video game anymore.
That's actually crazy.
I already forgot the patterns.
I can't believe I forgot the patterns!
I forgot the patterns!
Okay.
Holy shit!
This game is so much easier now!
If I had the upgrade when I was at my peak!
This is so bullshit!
Oh my...
Actually...
I wasted
so much time!
I wasted...
I actually...
Wasted so much time!
I wasted so much time!
I still keep doing a challenge run and she didn't even know...
Aww!
Sing me to sleep...
I can be a rock now!
I can be a rock!
Alright.
It's okay.
I'm so sad.
I legitimately could have fucking finished this so much earlier.
You would have been dead.
I turned into rock.
Alright.
I won on my worst run.
Wow Doki, it's so cool you gave the tiger a few chances before taking it.
Take the clothes off.
Yes, thank you in the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
I won, but why doesn't it feel like I won?
Why does it not feel like it?
Guys, why doesn't it feel like I was winning?
Alright, let's see.
Let's get...
Let's get this.
Because we're always running anyway.
We don't need HP.
All in on the damage, baby!
All in damage!
Yeah!
Damage!
No HP only.
I genuinely don't even think I need stamina.
Not gonna lie.
I feel like my stamina is like good enough.
Famous last words.
Just don't get hit, Doki.
Just don't get hit.
It has to be like...
A gift, right?
There has to be like an increased stamina.
Increased HP.
Permanently gift.
Around here.
The fact that I won on my worst fucking run.
That...
Stick to cereal, Tony.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, I need to use stone.
Alright, I need to use the stone.
How do I equip it?
Do I have to set the spells back at the shrine?
Alright.
Oh, it's another item?
Oh, I don't have the stone yet?
Oh, I thought it was my magic.
Oh, okay.
Oh,
I wish he was pa...
You know, if he was playing that song while I was beating the shit out of the T ambul...
Tony, I would have done even better.
I wouldn't need the staff.
That's all I'm saying.
If he was there earlier.
If he was singing during my fight.
What?
That would have actually been the first try.
Let's see.
No wonder people were yelling at me to craft.
I was like, what the fuck do you mean upgrade my staff?
There's no upgrades.
Oh, I can't be bothered.
It might be overkill, but honestly, it deserves it.
I'm not really ready to deal with these guys normally.
Monkey tired.
Monkey wants to rest.
Monkey knows.
Monkey lost 50 years of Monkey's lifespan.
Monkey desires retirement.
Why do I have to save Wukong?
Like, there's so many monkeys.
Oh, but you're the chosen one.
Like, can he choose many?
Why did he only choose one?
I feel like if I needed insurance, I was like, oh, there's...
Every god in the world fucking hates me.
Let me have one insurance monkey to bring me back if I die, like, again.
If I...
If I decided to be buried under a rock again for the 500 millionth time.
Why would I have one monkey insurance?
Why can't I be like the Horcruxes with like 500 monkeys gathering around trying to get the...
Trying to get this fucking relic?
I should be diversifying my assets.
Monkey should be diversifying.
Why?
What happened to monkey together is strong?
If I was Wukong, if I was Shroomhong and I've been stuck on the rock for the 500th time, and 500 million gods want to kill me, I would have just ripped a huge patch of my hair.
And be like, be free.
Be like...
Just a giant...
It'll grow back.
The hair will grow back.
Just rip a huge piece of hair.
Be like, be free.
Oh my god.
The world...
Everybody wants to kill me.
Anyway.
Alright.
Let's see.
Why am I the chosen one?
It should be chosen many.
Jesus Christ.
Fucking get out of here.
What?
What do you mean that barely did jack shit?
What kind of horse are you?
Oh my...
Okay, this horse is a little bit too strong.
This is a strong ass horse.
Okay.
Holy shit.
JK.
You are nothing without your shield.
What the fuck are you?
The spear bone.
The priests though were proud warriors.
Okay.
Oh, so they're priests.
Kill the priest.
That's not good.
I mean, I'm already going to hell anyway.
Wukong's definitely gonna go to hell.
I mean, he has several times.
So...
Very...
I mean, he is immortal.
So it's like...
Oh, hey, chest.
And you wonder why gods hate you.
It's not my fault.
If like...
Wukong's a little murder...
Murdery.
There's just too many gods.
You know?
Wukong had to like...
It was like...
What?
Why can't I gather this?
It's because there's this guy here?
Is that it?
Yeah, Wukong...
The reason why he's immortal...
Is because...
Um...
There was like a bunch of peaches on the floor.
And Wukong...
Simhong was like...
I'm hungry.
And then he ate all the peaches.
And now he can never die.
And that's why the gods keep fucking trapping a rock under him.
They're like...
We can't...
Oh, shit!
They're like...
We can't kill him.
So we're just gonna put a really, really heavy rock.
Like that's literally their strat.
They're like...
Alright, if we can't kill him...
We're just gonna put a very heavy rock on top of him.
And then...
That's it.
That's how we solve our problems.
That's...
That's actually...
They're like...
That's it.
This is how we solve all our problems.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Was that Splinter?
Goodbye, Splinter.
Oh, were you guarding that?
Was that your life savings?
He was like...
It's okay.
Even though I'm dead.
At least I will forever have that one life savings.
Yeah.
He's also erased his name from the Book of Death.
So he's like extra immortal.
Yeah.
That's why...
That's what I'm saying!
He knows he's fucking...
He knows he's gonna be...
The gods wanna trap him under that fucking rock.
Then why is there one chosen monkey?
That's what I'm saying!
You should have more monkeys!
There should be more monkey insurance at this point.
There should be more monkey insurance.
There's a chosen...
But why does it have to be chosen one?
It doesn't have to be!
He didn't have to make it harder for himself!
Boom.
There you go.
He thought one is enough.
Yeah!
After being trapped in the rock for the...
For the 500th time!
All right.
Let's get these jars here.
How many times is...
Okay.
To be fair.
He's not known...
I mean...
He's like...
He's...
He's smart.
But like...
Also not really.
Like sometimes he's very smart and then sometimes he's not.
He's like...
I could do the smart thing or I could do something really funny.
I think he's like...
He's sort of like me.
I'll be like...
I could do something that seems easy and smart to do.
But then like...
It won't be as funny though.
It's...
He's only monkey.
Oh shit!
He's like...
Yeah.
But like...
Will it be funny?
He would be a good streamer.
If he was a streamer in our day...
He would...
He would 100%...
He would 100% make so much money as a streamer.
He'd be like...
What?
Hey Wukong!
Today I'm gonna prank the guy!
They're not gonna expect that.
What would his fan name be?
What would his...
What would his fan name be guys?
If he was a streamer?
The monkey...
Hey monkeys!
Today we're gonna be pranking Erlang.
He's not gonna expect it.
The primates!
Oh my god!
Wait!
The primates!
The fellow primates!
Oh my god!
Wait!
Primates are so good!
Holy shit!
I wish Wukong was a Vtuber so he can call his fans the primates.
What?
That's perfect.
Alright.
What the fuck?
Okay.
That's what it was.
That's like...
What the fuck is that sound?
Who the fuck is like breathing heavily?
I don't know.
I wish he was a streamer.
Just kidding.
So I'd be like...
Hey primates!
Today we're gonna be...
Alright.
Let's see.
Where do we go?
This is just a dead village.
What do I do at this dead village?
Oh!
Ow!
That's not...
That's very rude of you.
That was so rude.
Alright.
Goodbye.
I'm Sumong.
And welcome to jackass.
Okay.
Thank you for the super chat Moose.
Thank you.
Alright.
Nice.
What did I get?
I got a core.
Okay.
I need a heal.
Where the fuck am I supposed to go?
I'll always be lost.
I'll never be different.
Okay.
I need a heal.
I feel like I...
I definitely feel like I skipped a lot of bosses.
Because I...
I got so fucking lost that I feel like I skipped so many bosses getting here.
No!
Not him!
Oh my god!
The horse!
That's so awkward.
I used my fucking power up on the goddamn zombies.
I'm so sad.
Oh no.
Okay.
It's time to send the baby in.
Did I not hit a baby?
Did I?
Oh.
Oh no.
No!
How did I roll back in?
How did I manage to roll back in?
Okay.
Maybe I can...
I can...
Maybe I can cheese this.
Maybe he's stuck.
Okay.
Nice.
Poke!
Okay.
We did it.
Boom!
All right.
Oh, thank god cheese works.
Oh, thank god.
I love cheesing stuff.
Oh.
With the power of cheese.
Cheese!
Nice.
All right, off we go.
Oh.
Hey, there's something over here.
Oh, no, that's just...
It's just textures not loading.
I was like, what's that thing that's loading?
You know, I'm almost, like, sure I'm home, except for the murdering part.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Oh, what the fuck?
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
That's...
THERE'S THREE OF THEM!
Okay.
Alright.
THERE'S LIKE THREE OF THEM!
THIS ISN'T FAIR!
What you gonna do?
Oh shit!
Wait, he can cheese too!
He fucking got me through the rock!
Okay.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
He's stuck.
Where did he go?
Wait, what the fuck?
What?
Wait, what?
Oh my god!
Bro, did he spawn?
There's how to do that?
Oh my god!
Bro can just de-spawn!
Jesus Christ.
That's actually fucked, man.
That's so messed up.
I swear to god, if you fucking de-spawn, I swear to god.
I swear to god.
Oh.
That's alright.
Okay.
No!
No, no, no!
Fuck!
I don't have a lot of HP right now!
No!
Come on!
Where did he spawn?
No!
No, no, no!
Oh god!
Oh, I have to recharge!
Oh!
Okay.
Nice, alright.
No!
I got one more!
I got one more in me!
Okay.
Long stick.
Boom!
Nice.
Oh, no!
Come on!
I got another in me!
Oh, thank god.
Not even close.
Not even close!
And he gave me silk, too!
Oh, my god.
We're okay.
We got the right imperial guard.
Oh, my god.
I can't believe I wasted so much HP.
I wasted so much HP, too.
That's the worst part.
Where are the incense?
Where the fuck am I supposed to heal?
Oh, it heals your back.
Oh, that's how I was supposed to heal.
That's how.
Thank god.
Got a little worried there.
I like how you're like, that's how.
Alright, nice.
Nice.
It's actually crazy how easier the game got after you upgrade your staff.
Guys, did you guys know you can upgrade your staff?
Fucking crazy.
Crazy mechanic, guys.
Never expected it.
I just, I discovered it.
Patented by Doki Bird.
Damn.
Yeah, isn't that wild?
Oh, hey.
Invincibility gatter.
Okay, never mind.
It was not that invincible.
That's gonna be like, oh shit, guys.
Invincibility gatter.
Let's go.
Alright.
Poke.
That's fucking right.
Guys, you think I don't know your zombies?
Guys, I just killed like 500 of them.
You think you're different?
You'll be like, no, she'll not expect that.
She expected all the other ones, but us three sitting there?
She'll think we're actually dead dead.
Alright, nice.
Okay.
We got her.
They're zombies, Doki.
They can't comprehend thought.
They don't know what's going on.
Alright.
Let's see.
Can I go inside this house?
There's an inside.
I can see that there's an inside.
It'll work one day.
They clearly designed the inside.
I should be let in.
You can tell that they designed the inside.
Okay.
Wait.
Oh, there it is.
I was like, there has to be like an item here.
There's no way that there isn't an item.
Alright.
Nice.
Gold and silk.
I always need more silk.
Let me in.
Alright.
Open sesame.
Avelion.
Thank you for the 10 gifted ships.
Thank you.
Oh my God.
Where do I go?
Is there any extra?
Oh, there's hidden loot.
Which I didn't see.
I knew there was going to be more.
There's going to be hidden loot.
Nice.
Alright.
Up we go.
Up the mountains I go.
Wait.
But like, what if I have to go down though?
Okay.
But like, I know I have the option to...
Oh, I...
Yeah.
We were supposed to go up.
There's like literally nothing here.
Unless...
There's a little end in here.
Oh.
Nope.
That's just the scenery.
Alright.
Up we go.
Oh.
There's the yellow paint.
Oh my God.
We finally got the yellow paint.
We finally got the yellow paint guys.
There it is.
The yellow paint.
They patch that just for me.
After using plays horror mode, the next rocks solid cost no mana.
What the hak?
I'm not going to use rocks.
I feel like the cloud sweep is just better.
I don't know.
I feel like that's just a better weapon in general.
A better skill in general.
That's what I mean.
Alright.
What the fuck?
Can I see you?
Brock says it can parry?
Yeah, but like, you know I'm not good at that.
Hahaha.
Pew!
Oh shit, that's not what I wanted.
Oh, I'm too far.
Too far.
I went too far.
Wait, did he die?
Oh no, he's over there.
Alright.
Guys, what is better then?
Parry or...
Sorry.
Ghost or... Sorry.
Cloud or...
I'll get it right eventually!
It only took me like three chances to figure out the right one.
Which is a better skill?
Cloud or rock?
I need to rest up.
I have to fight that guy again.
I realize I had no mana.
Depends on the boss, really.
I had to fight him again because I realized I forgot to get my mana.
Oh shit!
Depends on my skill?
I don't know.
I can't tell which is like...
Which one would be better for me.
Alright.
Come on.
Get over here.
Boom!
Yeah, that's right.
No more shield for you.
No more shield for you, bitch!
Oh shit!
Okay.
Even though he doesn't have a shield, he still hits pretty hard.
I only have stamina!
I don't need it!
Alright.
Nice.
For normal mods?
Oh, I've been using clouds for not normal mods.
You haven't tried... You know, I'll try stone.
Just for you guys.
What if I can poke him off?
Nope.
They have invisible walls.
Okay.
I'll try this stone.
Let's see.
Set spells.
Should be this.
Okay.
Guys,
they can shatter the rock.
Guys.
Can the bosses shatter it?
Alright.
Let's try it out.
I'm just wondering if the bosses can shatter it though.
That's what I'm worried about.
Get him out of here.
Nice.
I'm gonna rob you now.
Wait, who's still here?
God damn it!
You're fucking... Stay dead!
Go to hell!
Go to hell and accept your judgement!
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh!
Yay!
Like, I'm gathering all these ingredients but I'm not...
I'm not using any of the items that these ingredients make.
You don't understand, chat.
I need it on the final boss.
Guys, I'll use...
Guys, I gotta save for the final boss.
The final boss is gonna be so hard.
It's gonna be so hard if I don't save it for that!
Chat!
Who's he?
He looks like a particular individual.
What's my... Where's my son?
I can't find him?
Jesus Christ!
What the fuck?
Boom!
How did I miss?
Holy shit!
Okay.
Oh!
Haha!
Okay, apparently, like, I did more...
I did enough damage where, like, he got...
Oh, fuck!
Oh, shit!
Okay!
Okay, old man!
Oh, my God!
God!
Yes!
Did I do it?
Did I time it perfectly?
I can't tell!
Oh, fuck!
He took me out of the sky!
Oh, no!
No!
It's not fair!
He has such long days!
Oh!
I'm panicking too!
With the sheer power of panic!
I did it!
Oh, thank God!
You'll never find your son!
That's fucking right!
You wasted 80 years of your life!
Oh!
Wait!
New...
New skill?
New summon?
Wait!
Is he stronger than Baby?
There's no way!
Now I have an 80-year-old man to transform into!
Hehehe!
How would we...
Oh, fuck!
You guys had a day!
How do we know?
That's how you'll know!
A day is plenty enough time!
I need to know!
Which is better, Baby or Christy?
Oh shit.
I know I should like... I liked how I used that.
Okay, I used the fucking...
the heavy combo on the fucking zombie.
Like, yeah, that's priorities right there.
All right, there has to be loot here.
Why else is it...
like this?
The wikis haven't been written yet.
God damn it.
How would I know?
How would I know which is stronger?
Baby or grandpa?
Oh, hey.
Oh, I finally got new wine.
God, fucking finally.
New wine time.
Wait, what is this new wine?
Inventory.
Oh, never mind.
Wait, what did I get?
That's not wine.
Is that normal... what is that?
Man bat.
Get out of here, man bat.
Okay, I actually want to get the archer out.
Oh shit.
Man bat, I'm here to collect rent.
You're two months behind rent.
Rent, man bat.
Haha.
That's right.
Man bat, you're two months behind rent.
Rent, man bat.
I'm the shark.
I'm here to collect your hard rent.
Alright.
There you go.
Go this way.
I'm the lone shark.
This way?
Okay, no.
That's the wall.
I'm sorry, I thought there would be loot!
I'm always thinking, loot?
Loot?
Like those little seagulls.
From Finding Nemo.
Oh, loot.
The lone monkey is here.
It's a cave.
Yeah, but like real estate is hard right now.
Even caves cost 5 million.
It's the experience.
Alright?
It's the experience cave.
Oh, the stone vanguard.
Wait, what happens if rock...
Wait, I don't have Wait, oh my god.
That's a strong-ass fucking rock.
Okay, nice.
Fire versus rock!
Clearly that would do a lot of damage!
Guys, I don't understand.
Why is fire not doing a lot of damage?
Oh, I forgot I'm also rock.
I already forgot how to aim my power up.
Jesus Christ.
Oh.
I don't know his moves!
He's just a giant rock!
Like, it's so hard to predict too!
Oh my god.
Please.
Wait, this is actually so hard to predict because he's literally just a fucking rock.
Okay.
Is he lost?
Oh shit!
No, he was not lost.
He was not lost.
Guys!
Ah!
Guys, it's over.
Wait, he does have some cheeks!
Holy shit!
Wait, who fucking designed you?
Big baby!
Boom!
Oh, rock angry.
Rock very angry.
Wait, wait, mini rock?
Rock was pregnant?
For god's sake!
Oh my god.
Congratulations.
It was six tuplets.
Oh my god.
Oh, I have to do this thing.
I think I...
I'm just gonna run.
I'm trying to figure out if I want to use baby or grandpa.
Okay, wait.
Where's the transformation?
Six?
No.
Advance.
There you go.
Wait, no.
Oh wait, but I do have...
I want to upgrade my thrust.
Okay.
Finally.
Alright, two to three.
Oh, nice!
Okay, we need that.
Um...
Let's see...
I wanna get...
I'll get health.
Alright.
There's a closer shrine?
I missed the shrine?
God!
Where's the...
Wait, I have another one?
Oh, the...
Oh, the rock one.
Where's the...
transformation again?
Oh, here it is.
Equipment.
Alright.
Oh, it's still not as good.
I feel like big baby is still the strongest.
Let's see...
Oh, cultivate.
Do I have upgrades for big baby?
Baby!
No.
God damn it.
Change your gourd?
Oh, do I have new gourd?
Wait, I can change my gourd?
Where's gourd?
I can change my gourd.
I've had it since beta.
Wait!
Life is cruel.
Life is so cruel.
Since the start of the game.
Alright, time to fucking kill the rock.
Why is life so cruel?
Versus the staff.
Now it's the coin.
Oh my god, it's time to collect my rent and collect my rent again.
Why do I make this game harder for myself?
I've basically been gaming this entire time.
I could have finished this game already.
I bet you if I knew about all of this, this game would have been done yesterday.
I would have one-shot this game.
Where the fuck is the...
I tried black scenes twice.
I didn't see the red dot on the Gordon and figured you noticed it.
But it was most naturally comedic.
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It was just funny.
Oh wait, there it is.
Wait, I can... I don't have to wake up the rock?
The rock was op... No!
How did you wake up?
Oh my god!
The rock was optional.
The rock was optional!
Alright.
Oh my god.
Oh, I fucked up.
I fucked up.
I had to...
Oh, it's not optional?
It's not optional?
I can't even sneak past the rock?
Gotta fucking slap his ass.
Boom!
Slap that!
Oh shit!
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I'll be more polite.
You're more than your ass.
I'm so sorry.
You're right.
You're so much more than your ass.
You're so much more.
You're right.
I'm sorry for assuming that.
Alright.
Freeze the rock.
My god.
Oh, it's the children!
It's the children!
Oh, I fucked up the timing.
Doki.
He has a wonderful personality, Doki.
He's not just his ass.
I'm sorry!
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
I felt like that was not really a very good parry anyway.
Oh, shit!
Jesus Christ.
This is so difficult!
Guys, I don't...
I don't think I'm gonna make it.
I'm literally 1HP.
Oh my god!
Okay!
Woah!
Okay.
Alright.
Awesome.
Okay.
I got a regen.
I got a regen!
You guys, I'm so far off.
Oh my god.
It's not looking so good for Doki!
He slapped me!
Oh fuck, okay.
Why is he so tanky?
Oh, because he's a rock.
I get it.
No, no, that makes sense.
No, he's right.
You're right.
He's a rock.
I'm gonna... I'm gonna use the cloud.
I can't time this.
Insane revelation.
Alright.
Let's see.
We're gonna use the cloud.
I can't time this correctly.
Alright, goodbye.
Guys, we need paper.
We need...
Guys.
We...
Where can I upgrade paper to paper?
I have to go to the other side?
Alright.
Yeah, I rather... I wanted...
Thank you.
See, this is why I waited another day before I play it again.
I knew at one point...
I told you guys.
One day is all it takes for backseaters to figure this out.
This is exactly why.
Alright, goodbye.
See, we gotta go this way.
Imagine if I was there during launch.
I would have never known.
Oh, shit.
Whoops.
Alright.
We go to the right.
To the right, to the right.
Alright.
There shouldn't be another guard here, right?
Is there another incense area here?
Oh, there it is.
Nice.
Huh?
Alright,
here we go.
We can finally rest.
Alright.
Why were you chanting, Mr. Rock?
I'm gonna take your eyes.
And worry for... Oh, hello there.
Hello.
Hey.
Oh, shit.
Sorry, was that... Oh, shit.
Sorry.
Shit, was that... Oh, okay.
Alright, sir.
Alright, sorry for taking your eyes.
I did not... That was... It was just a... It was just a silly joke, sir.
I'm sorry.
I didn't mean to take your eyes.
I did not mean to take your eyes.
Okay.
Alright, well, it's too bad.
Eyes are gone.
Alright, we're gonna go fight the rock.
He's not gonna follow me, right?
To the rock?
There's no way.
That would be so silly.
That would be so silly if he followed me all the way to the rock.
Surely not, yeah?
There's no way.
Fire versus rock!
Who will win?
I don't know, guys.
I think... I think fire can burn rock if it's enough fire.
All I'm saying is that...
If there was enough fire going on, maybe... maybe?
You don't know that!
Guys!
Boom!
Smack that!
Oh, shit!
Sorry!
Smack me!
Might as well smack me too, I guess.
Jesus!
I need to time that better.
Okay.
You remember.
Boom!
That's fucking right.
Oh, nice.
Oh, not nice!
It's the children!
They're here for the money payments!
How do I even know they're mine?
I know I was born from rocks, but how would I know?
Are you fucking...
I can't.
I...
Fuck you.
All right.
The child support.
Oh, no!
He's here for the child support.
How do I even know they're mine, though?
There could be anybody's rock, children!
Oh, no!
The child support.
Oh, we're gonna have the child support.
Oh my God.
I like how every time, like...
Every time, like, I don't fight a monster, I just forget how to fight them.
Oh, please!
This is where I die.
They have your...
They have the...
They could be anybody's Rockids!
I'm not the only Rock- I am the only Rockmonkey out there.
But like, but like, it could be anybody's.
It could be, it could be anybody.
It could just be me.
How would I know?
There's so many other Rocks, Rocks here.
Wait, what's this?
Knock, knock.
What?
What the fuck am I supposed to do interacting with this?
It's bound by six seals.
Get up!
This is the first time I've met this Rock!
It could be me!
It could be anybody!
All I'm saying is like...
This is the very first time I've even seen this Rock.
Like, it could be anybody's Rock.
Alright.
Boom!
Big baby!
Smack that!
Oh shit!
I need to stop smacking that.
I can't help it.
Oh...
I mean...
Damn!
Oh shit!
Damn me!
Okay, I need to like figure out like the proper movesets for this guy.
Woo!
Oh no, it's the children already?!
The child support already gave it you last year!
I don't understand!
I paid last year!
You didn't pay more?!
You can't just pay yearly?!
Is that how child support works?!
What the fuck do you mean?!
I'm not a bad person.
Alright.
Let's see.
Nice, there we go.
Alright, there we go.
It's fine.
He's gonna get closer to me, right?
Okay.
That's fucked.
He literally threw a Rock at me.
Holy shit.
Why is he so mad?!
What did I do?!
What could I have possibly done?!
Smack!
Okay.
Alright.
Smack!
Nice.
Smack again!
Okay.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh, I forgot that was the pa- Oh no, not the children, not the child support.
Please, I already paid last year's.
Please.
Paid last year's.
Is that not enough, children?!
I'm just a monkey!
It doesn't pay a lot to be a monkey!
I don't have hands!
Oh!
Shit!
I don't know why you think I make a lot of money!
I literally was- I'm literally just a fucking rock monkey!
Oh god.
Oh my god.
I'm so scared.
He wants more child support!
One fear.
Child support.
No!
One fear!
Oh god.
Oh god!
Guys, I don't- I don't know, guys.
Oh!
Come
on!
I don't do enough damage!
Argh!
He is actually!
Oh my God!
I cannot!
I cannot do it!
I'm 3D!
Oh, I got it!
I got 2!
I was like, I'll hit it before he hits me!
Oh, my God!
That's really not fair!
This is not fair!
Oh, my God!
Boom!
How does he think?
Like, have we ever thought that I'm the victim?
Maybe I'm the victim here!
Yeah!
Oh, God!
No!
I was stranded!
Wait, what?
I got stunned!
It didn't even hurt me!
Wait, what?
Okay, now it hurts me.
Okay.
Fuck!
I keep forgetting that!
Oh!
She's the victim.
Refuses to pay child support.
Oh, God!
Piff!
Nice!
Slap that ass!
That's fucking right!
Boom!
Last final slap!
God, I missed that ass!
Okay.
Come on!
Slap!
Oh!
We're fine, we're fine, we're fine!
Everything is fine!
Nice!
Oh, I forgot about the second move!
Slap!
Oh, okay, we're good!
We're okay!
We're so healthy!
Nice!
Oh, we're not healthy anymore!
But unless...
Oh, my God!
I keep forgetting to use the... the other move!
Oh!
Oh, no!
He slapped the cord out of my hand!
That should be illegal!
Oh, my God!
She's throwing rocks!
She's so mad!
Why are you so angry?
Oh!
Not the children!
Stop sending kids into our arguments!
This is between you and me!
It's like she's angry.
This fight is between you and me!
Don't get their kids involved!
Oh!
Oh, no!
Narangi!
It's your turn to spend time with the children!
The kids have nothing to do with this!
You can't escape the child's support!
It's your turn to deal with the children!
But, like...
You don't understand!
I have got a game with the boys today!
I can't look after them!
It's boys' night!
What they do every night is boys' night.
The rock missus doesn't know that, though.
Ah, fuck!
Okay.
He has to get closer to me, right?
All right.
Nice.
Okay.
We dodged that.
All right.
Come on.
Fucking hell!
Nice!
Dodge!
Oh, no!
Not the children!
Oh, God!
It's the kids again!
It's the kids!
Oh!
Smack!
Come on.
Boom!
All right.
Oh!
Oh...
Dodge!
All right.
I have full focused now.
I need a full focus.
Smack!
At least I really don't want this.
This is harder than Tony the tiger.
No!
Hurry up.
Oh, is he harder than Tony the Tiger?
Oh, please.
No!
Oh shit, that was close.
Oh, is he so much more difficult than Tony?
He's just a rock!
Oh!
Okay.
Oh my god, I got smacked again!
Come on, come on, please.
No!
Oh, I dodged it just in time!
Oh god.
No, not the children.
Not the kids again.
Oh, please.
Oh, thank god.
Thank god!
That's bullshit.
That's actually bullshit!
That should have been a hit!
Alright.
That should have been a dodge!
That's bullshit too.
Alright.
Wolf time!
Oh shit!
With the power of Wolf.
Oh my god.
Don't get greedy.
Don't get greedy, Toki.
That's what they... That's what she was!
Shit.
Okay.
My last heal.
That's what she wants.
Come on.
Nice.
Yes!
No more child support!
Thank god!
Let's go!
Oh!
And she disappeared.
No one knows where she went.
No one knows where she went!
She just disappeared, guys!
She just vanished!
Holy fuck.
That was so much work.
She just vanished.
We'll never know what happened to her.
I was going to pay for the child support!
But like...
But like, she just disappeared.
How else was I going to pay if I don't know where she was?
That's so unfortunate.
Oh well.
Yeah, she just vanished.
Don't look in the swamp.
She just disappeared.
Just like that.
Right before the court case, too.
But...
No more child support declares the murder.
You know, I heard those kids weren't even mine.
Maybe that's why I turned into a monkey.
Hey, how do I get over there?
Is that it?
Was there nothing here?
Oh, it was just a plant.
So was me.
Oh yeah, it was...
I should like the thrusting more, but I...
Alright, it's fine.
Am I going to get poisoned?
No.
It's just a regular plant.
That's right, give me that ginseng.
Oh no.
Oh no, that was not just...
That was poison.
I deserve that.
Wait, which way do I go?
Left or right?
I don't even know.
Okay, so I walked into that.
I definitely walked into that.
It's like there's the Buddha eyes on the other side.
I'll just walk this way.
My old man, I learned my lesson this time.
What?
Okay.
What a weird dream I had.
I wonder what's over here.
Guys, you wouldn't believe it.
I had the weirdest, freaky dream today.
How?
How do I dodge it?
Oh, wait, I got an idea.
I got an idea.
What's blocking?
Anyway.
No, I got a better idea.
Sorry, I don't understand that concept.
That's fucking right.
Oh my god.
I'm going to use everything I know.
I'm going to use everything I know against you.
I'm going to use everything.
Can't do anything now.
That's fucking right.
They'll trap you in the corner.
That's right.
That's fucking right.
What you going to do now?
Oh, thank fucking god.
I'm sorry.
I used everything I had.
Oh my god.
The rat governor is still not as strong as baby.
Oh, it's time to mat meditate.
They'll never find the body.
That's it.
No more child support.
What an interesting reflection.
What are you guys talking about?
I'm just meditating.
The rest is silence.
Alright, let's see.
Oh, hey loot.
I love loot.
I've attained inner peace.
Oh, hey.
Oh, mana.
Nice.
I'd like me some mana.
What could it mean?
The scholars have been discussing this for generations.
Shroom Hong wrote on the tablet.
They'll never discover the body.
What could he possibly mean by that?
Wait.
After all, unless the best one leaves four to engage them, he'd be saying to a barrage.
Hold light tack to... or after performing tactical...
I actually want to get the more foundation stuff.
Oh!
Wait, that's good.
What could he mean?
And then next to the tablet were bunches of pebbles next to it.
I don't know if it correlates or anything.
Oh, sand.
Yay!
Ow!
How the fuck do I dodge this?
Just on the slide!
Yippee!
All right.
The sand burn.
Oh, hey.
Him again.
Yeah, I guess so, I guess so.
Oh, hey.
What are you doing?
You're just going to say the cougar?
Oh yeah.
For now, I think.
He is going to take from you.
He ain't dog.
No, he ain't.
He ain't.
Yeah, he's not that I say he ain't.
He's not.
Oh, my God.
He's not going to give it back to me.
One.
He's not going to throw it back to me.
He's going to throw it back to me.
What the fuck did he give me?
Oh!
I finally have duplicate powers!
Oh my god, the ladies are gonna love this.
Alright, let's see.
Let's get that incense.
Alright, rest time.
Alright, nice.
Alright, uh, there's a door?
It's not a door.
That's a wall.
Oh.
I found the rock.
I did it!
Wait, where do we go?
But like, there's stuff over here though.
I'm gonna go this way.
I see stuff I want.
Absorb.
Have I ever opened the other door?
Most likely not.
I'm so fucking lost, guys.
Like, this entire game I'm like just lost.
Where are you?
Are you crawling?
You're like a floor.
Guys, we all learned how to walk on our two legs.
What the fuck are you doing?
The humans are gonna think we're freaks.
Oh, it's the weasel captain.
Guys, I did learn to...
Before I...
What the fuck?
What the fuck is that?
Smack.
Stop smacking yourself.
You know what?
Let's grab all these guys too.
Let's get them all in this action.
That's fucking right.
Ow.
Okay.
Alright, now I know what that is.
Let's get them all in!
Wait, I can get poisoned?
As the fox?
As the what?
Okay.
Alright, we're fine.
Everything is a-okay.
This is so easy.
Oh no.
Wait, is he healing?
Wait, he's healing?
That should be legal!
Only I should be able to heal!
Oh god.
Got the poison.
No!
What the fuck?
Friendly fire.
It's like, who are you?
Sorry.
There was some...
Some unfortunate friendly fire action.
There.
Whoops.
Oh my god, I already used up all my...
Jesus.
It's fine.
It's not greed.
It's not greed because he's gonna die!
Right here!
Fucking easy.
When the boss heals.
When did I kill?
Oh, there he is.
The gore-eyed Taoist.
A strange man with a lump on his back and a staff of blood red hue.
He leaps and bounds with eerie might.
Alright.
Nice.
Oh!
God.
Fucking...
I fucking knew it.
It's old.
Please.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
Bro, I'm trying to...
BRO, I'M TRYING TO ABSORB!
Get out of here!
I was trying to absorb.
The invincibility frames, man.
Bro, why is he so tanky?
Oh, god.
Thank you.
Don't touch me.
Give me... give me six feet.
Nice, here you go.
Thank god for the invincibility frames.
Oh!
Is that another Buddha?
Oh, nope.
Nope.
It's pretty though!
Free the nipple!
Alright, was that it?
Oh no, there's more here.
Never punished.
Those mimics actually fuck with me though.
Holy shit.
Guys, I don't know if I'm flowing the right way.
Like...
I don't know!
There's a door in there, but then there's a whole new pathway here!
Where the fuck am I?
There's no...
But where does this door go to?
Where... go where?
Yes!
I'm gonna go through that door.
I'm gonna do it.
But I'm gonna rest.
The yellow paint, Toki!
Follow the yellow paint!
Alright.
Let's see.
Someone said I got Gord upgraded.
Is that true?
Nope.
That's a fucking lie.
Alright.
That's progress?
Then what the fuck is over there?
Alright, we're gonna check out what's over there, I guess.
Toki is turning to the west.
There's no other way.
Like, I don't know what to tell you.
Alright, then we'll go this way and see what happens.
At least I can just run past these guys.
They're not important.
Follow the yellow brick road.
Woo.
I love gathering ingredients I'll never use.
Alright.
Past the bridge.
Oh, shit.
That's fine.
It's wolf time.
Wolf.
Will I get any other transformation but wolf?
Why is it always wolf?
Surely there's like somebody else, right?
Nice.
Why is it always wolf?
Haha.
When did I get two wolves?
That's when things get spicy.
Wait, he's still alive?
Why is he still alive?
You were like 1 HP.
Wow!
That was a good hiding spot.
Oh no, there's more pathways?
The coughing baby.
Hey, little monkey.
I'm here.
I don't have a bone.
Shake it.
Huh?
What the fuck?
Child?
What the f- The wind and sand are gone.
I'll be fine.
What?
Look, you're a foreigner.
Don't look at me like that.
This place is so much fun.
The old man hiding in the rock.
The pig that stole wine in the village.
And the manager...
I won't tell you.
Oh, you fucker!
You fucker.
I fucking hate mimics in any game.
It's mimics and poison swamps.
Alright.
How many kids does this monkey have?
What do you mean?
He didn't find the body.
Wait, where do I go?
What?
What happened?
Where do I go?
Wait, what?
Is that it?
Oh.
No, that's nothing.
What?
This is a dead end.
Look up.
But it's a dead end.
Huh?
But we finally found him, the coughing baby.
The legends are true, chat.
What?
We finally found him.
We finally found the coughing baby.
Yeah, but where do I go for this quest?
Think 3D?
Here?
I'm thinking 3D.
What do you mean, think 3D?
The legend of the coughing baby.
It's true.
Oh!
You fucking liar.
This is a fucking wall.
It's a, it's a wall, I can't go behind it.
I got baited.
You mean look up?
There's a bridge.
Do I go to that bridge?
How do I get to that bridge?
Oh, it's a dead end.
Oh, thank God.
Thank God, for back seaters.
You guys would have, and I know you guys would have tried to kill me.
I know you guys would try to make me stay there for 20 more minutes.
Just to be like, Doki, you got one guy.
This was going to be a one guy moment.
You think I don't know that?
You think I don't know what you guys will do to me?
Hey, there's too many.
I hate it when there's so many fucking doors.
Wait, that door doesn't work.
Okay.
There's so many doors, but that one door doesn't work.
Alright, that's good to know.
The chosen one guy.
Alright, I guess we go this way then.
Oh!
The other door.
Open sesame!
Where am I?
Where is this place?
Okay, that scared me.
I don't like this cave.
Wait, isn't that the...
Wait!
Isn't that the cave where I killed the child?
No, this is not.
Wait, is it?
Wait, is this the same... I don't know where I am.
Yeah, this is where I killed the child.
Oh, I found a shortcut!
But what am I going to do here?
Why am I here?
Just to suffer?
And then this is where I killed the man back.
What is that?
The village?
Where's the village?
Is it west?
It's the village west.
Guess where...
Where's the village?
Well, there's the temple.
That's the temple where I killed the fucking tiger.
Isn't that the item for the... the thing?
Here too?
Everything is west.
Is it also west, guys?
Alright.
Can I activate this now?
I should be able to.
This is where I killed Tony the Tiger.
Whoa!
Dad?
What the fuck?
This is... that's an Aladdin moment right here.
Tony's dad?
Cave of Wonders?
Whoa, what's that?
What is this?
More zombies.
Okay.
Oh, more sick!
Thank God!
Thank God there's so many bugs here!
Nice.
Alright, I love loot.
Loot, loot, loot.
Oh, increases maximum health.
Okay, I definitely need that.
We're gonna kill another god.
This has to be a boss, right?
Like what else could it be?
What the fuck are you?
Phew!
Oh, I'm dead!
Oh shit!
Oh, there's so many!
Too many!
Too many children!
Oh my god, how many are there?
Holy shit!
How many?
We have a problem!
Oh shit!
Oh, they're so fast.
They're actually so fast.
Oh my god, they're so fucking fast.
Too many wine!
Too many corn wine!
Oh god.
This is it.
There you go.
Now I can chill.
Oh, I cannot chill.
Never mind.
Use all your magic!
Guess it was worth it.
Guys, I had to.
I had to use everything.
I can't.
I cannot deal with all of them.
And thus all my magic is now gone.
Worth it.
When you get bullied in PE.
Guess it was worth it.
We might need to fight somebody here later.
I don't understand.
It was worth it.
I wish, like, mana regenerates.
I guess, like, it'd be too OP, I guess.
But, like, god, it's so frustrating.
You know?
It's so frustrating that you can only, like... Oh, it's slide time!
Yay!
Ooh.
Oh, wait, what?
There's an incense here.
Okay, nice.
It'd be nice.
Oh, there's mana regen later?
Oh, thank god.
I feel like...
Um...
I feel like it would definitely be a lot better.
If, like, we definitely have, like, mana regen.
It's just very frustrating that, um, I have to always go to the rest stop for it.
I guess spells are pretty overpowered.
Yeah.
I guess it'll make the game way too easy.
Wait, what's this?
Is it just decoration?
I assume, like, I don't know.
It's a different color.
What if I mega smash it?
Wait, what does this do?
Is it just... decoration?
It's light.
It's just light.
I missed the NPC.
There's an NPC?
Whoa.
Yippee, the slide.
How did I miss an NPC?
Oh my god.
Okay, let's...
Apparently, I have a gourd update too.
No, I don't.
No, I fucking don't.
What?
Okay.
Travel.
Where was it?
Here?
Oh, temple entrance.
Oh, I have to go to Hong Kong Monkey.
Okay.
Wait, I can travel between chapters?
I thought I was stuck in sand forever!
I didn't realize.
Oh my god.
Why do I never realize this?
I legitimately thought I was stuck in sand forever.
Okay.
Oh my god, I can go back to the Hong Kong Monkey.
Why would you ever want to leave Sand Land, Doki?
Why would you ever want to leave?
We are...
We aren't trapped?
Alright, while we wait for this to load, I need to go grab some water.
I'll be right back.
I drank up all my water.
Oh, well, we're here.
I'm still gonna make you guys wait.
I'm back.
Sorry, I had to kick Dad out too.
Because he was like, Can I come inside now?
And I was like, Nope, nope.
Turn around.
Not inside the PC room.
Not inside the office.
Hello, Hong Kong Monkey.
Yo, Joe.
Choo choo.
Alright, let's see.
Oh my god, I can upgrade so much.
Wait, is this the...
Oh, wait, no, this is normal.
Okay.
Alright, upgrade drinks.
Oh!
Recovers more health.
Whoa!
Don't talk to me.
And now at the...
It's time to bring out the fancy wine.
I got the fancy wine now.
Man, Doki, you've changed.
Ever since you got that five-year coconut wine.
Oh my god, you've changed, Doki.
I'm starting my wine mom era.
Travel.
What's the town called, guys?
Is this the village entrance?
Is it the entrance of the...
The boxed wine auntie.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm the wine aunt now.
I got the...
Alright.
There was a frog?
I clearly have not been registering.
It's like, there was a frog?
I did not meet a frog.
I went straight to killing a boss.
Go backwards?
Go down?
Here?
Oh, you can tell I've never been here before.
You can tell I've never been down here.
Who's this?
Oh, wait.
Wait, you're an NPC!
Oh, okay.
Oh my god, somebody I don't kill.
That's new.
Oh, there he is!
Hello frog!
Good frog?
Not good frog!
Okay.
Guys, it was not a good frog.
I thought...
I thought he was...
I thought he was a good frog.
I don't know.
I don't know why I thought so.
I thought it'd be different.
Wait, he can interrupt my moves?!
That should be illegal!
He did!
He interrupted my moves!
Oh my god!
That's fucked.
That's actually fucked.
I didn't know he could do that.
Oh my god!
I'm fighting...
And then I got bored.
Goodbye.
I
was not expecting that!
I thought, you know...
I thought the fox was like, go talk to him, see what he wants.
And I was like, okay.
I didn't realize he was...
I thought we were going to have a negotiation.
You know, like have a little debate.
A little conversation.
I didn't think...
I didn't think he was going to beat me up.
I was just doing an errand.
I was just doing a fucking errand.
Okay.
The frog is not friend.
Who would have thought?
Frog not friend.
I can't wear pants!
Why is frog not friendly?
Okay.
Thank god at least...
Smack!
I learned how to smack.
Oh.
Whoa.
This is not fair!
Jesus!
Oh!
What the fuck is wrong with this frog?
Oh my god.
Okay.
I'm like not feeling so good right now.
My...
My guy is not feeling so good.
He...
He has a lot of electricity issues right now.
Oh my god.
He has a lot of electricity issues at the moment!
Let me stun you.
Let me fucking stun you.
Boom!
We did it.
We got Tab.
We got his babies too.
We...
Holy shit!
We got the kids.
We're getting the kids.
Dude don't Mind, please.
I got the children.
Are you seeing mashing the children in the pot!?
Masha+.
Just tell Masha in fact.
Come she sort out herself off.
No, no, no, no.
No.
I remember this...
That.
Aw.
I got medicine.
Okay.
Fix the zoom box?
How so?
The zoom... it didn't cut off anything.
I was looking at it.
Now go to the place.
Okay.
Back to the place.
Where is it?
It gets cut off?
Where?
Like the bottom?
Oh, I
didn't see... I didn't realize there were two lines.
I was like looking at it.
Where do I go?
Do I go back to the temple?
Is that it?
Oh, that's not what I want to do.
Where am I?
Oh, that's the arrow.
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
I found it.
Oh, I found it.
Oh, I can make medicine now.
That's funny that they think I'm going to use that.
Okay.
Down here.
There it is.
All right.
Now that I'm here, I'm ready to talk.
What?
Where's the NPC?
There's a well in the village?
Oh,
he's like... he liked the thing.
he's like...
he liked the thing.
Oh, he's like... he liked the thing.
He's a dog?
Who let this dog cook?
Oh, I got a mine core.
Nice.
And what is this?
Uh...
Upon use considerably...
Oh, it increases maximum health.
All right.
Okay.
Does it do it forever?
It seems like...
Does this do it forever?
Or nah?
Or like...
It's like temporary.
For a few minutes.
Okay.
No, fuck that shit.
You're not scamming me.
You're not...
Oh, there we go.
Now...
Now I can make actual medicine.
All right.
Let's see.
I have...
Maximum mana.
Stamina.
Defense.
Increases stamina.
Recovery rate.
Chill resistance.
Wait.
What should I get?
Guys.
What would be the best?
There's no damage.
So like now...
I don't know what...
Now it's hopeless for me.
Guys.
When there's no damage, I don't know what to do.
What do I do?
There's no damage.
Okay.
We'll do it.
We'll do HP.
He did not...
You know what he's saying there.
All right.
Nice.
Plus...
Is he going to do that every time?
That's...
I don't think I'd like that.
I'm just thinking.
Oh, no.
Is he going to do that every fucking time?
Every time I'm trying...
Okay.
Should I get...
What should I...
Now mana?
Oh, I can skip.
Oh, thank God.
I can...
I was going to say...
That's way too long.
All right.
And I see...
I still have...
I have two more.
Where do I put the last two in?
Chat.
Mana too?
Still mana?
Or...
Yeah, but I don't have a lot of mine core.
That's the thing.
I have to do it one by one because I don't have a lot.
I only had like seven.
Do I do...
Mana...
Stamina recovery rate...
Stam recovery rate is also good.
I'll do two then for it.
I'll just use up both of them.
All right.
Okay.
Nice.
Yay.
Okay.
We go...
All right.
The Children Well.
Where's the well?
Where is the well?
Is it still at the village?
I assume it's still at the village entrance.
Behind.
Can I open the door now?
Do I have to kill them to open the door?
Can I?
How the fuck do I get in?
I never figured out how to get in that door.
Wait, where am I?
Oh shit, I've never explored this.
Oh, it can be open from the other side.
Guys, it's time.
It's time to finally explore.
We never explored this area.
Finally, after defeating 500 other bosses, it's finally time to figure out where to go.
Oh my god, what the fuck did he do?
Oh, he tried to sparta me.
That's what.
What the fuck?
Where did you come from?
Rubbing it up.
Get over here.
Boom.
There we go.
No more fucking shields.
For you.
Sorry, it took me a while to rev that up.
Alright.
Where the fuck do I go to the other side?
Here?
That's where I went.
Oh, I guess it's here, right?
Oh, he's back?
No, fuck that.
I do not want to deal with that.
You're gonna have to chase me all the way here.
Okay, he's still chasing me, guys.
I thought he would stop.
You're gonna have to chase me all the way here.
Oh, but what if I have all of these guys here?
Yeah, that's right.
And then I'm gonna do this too.
Which one's the real monkey?
I say.
You'll never find me.
Which one's the real monkey?
Monkey!
Who could it be?
Jesus Christ, he's so tanky.
I hate this rat guy.
Alright, nice.
How do I get up there though?
Wait.
Oh no, is that the wizard?
Oh no.
It's him.
Oh no, it's the weaker version of him.
He's not him.
Thank God.
Okay, I had like PTSD from that one wizard.
Look, that one wizard was very scary.
No!
The stupid fucking arrows!
Alright.
How the fuck do I get to the high ground?
It's not fair!
I'm gonna figure it out.
I'm gonna beat the shit out of you.
How do I get?
I jump.
Oh shit, really?
But which way?
I'm never gonna figure it out, guys.
Wait, what the fuck?
This is a prehistoric rack.
It's an earth wall?
That's a rat!
What?
No way!
That's a fucking rat!
Oh, it's daddy!
That's a wolf!
It has a rat tail!
Guys, I think it got confused.
That's not a wolf.
A wolf rat.
Oh shit.
Oh, no.
I can't believe I cancelled my lock on at the last minute.
Like, what's wrong with me?
What's wrong?
How is that a fucking...
fucking abomination?
Alright, nice.
Oh, a rat.
Nice.
Even has a fucking rat tail!
Can you regen my stamina, though?
Okay, nice.
And then...
Oh, no.
Okay, heal time.
Oh, dodge.
Truly an earth wolf.
An earth wolf is just what rats are called, guys.
You don't understand.
Oh, shit!
Do I get to absorb you?
Yay!
Oh, I do!
Okay, I need to know what happened to you.
The soldiers in order to kill the hound were much troubled in spirit.
They buried the hound in the field upon the... Oh!
It's a dead wolf!
Oh!
He lost all his fur!
He's like a naked...
He's a naked wolf!
Absorbed.
Oh, that makes more sense now.
He's a naked mole wolf, yeah!
He's literally a naked mole wolf.
I was gonna say, I was like, that's just a giant fucking rat.
But now that I know it's a naked mole wolf.
Well, can I meditate here?
Oh, I should open the door too.
Yeah.
Door open time!
I finally explored this place.
Hey guys!
They're like, what the fuck?
You're not supposed to be able to open the door.
It's like, what the fuck happened?
Okay, nice.
Easy!
After killing that rat, you think I'm scared of you?
You brought a bow to a sad fight.
Absorbed.
Wait a minute.
You're not the pizza order.
Nice.
I got the rat archer.
Now where do we go?
Oh, this guy like, just watched as his friends all die.
There's a horseman?
How many fucking animals do I have to kill?
Wait, there's stuff here.
There's more materials I'm never gonna use.
Alright.
Yeah, I didn't- I got lost a lot.
I don't know if you guys noticed, but yeah, I got lost a lot.
If you think I found somebody, you're like, Doki found this person?
Most likely, I did not.
The rate of me figuring- knowing where I am is quite high.
No, quite low.
I couldn't even get that right.
Where the fuck's the well?
It's just all sand!
Is it this way?
Oh, is that the well?
That has to be the well.
No, that- I was here.
I was here.
Where am I?
Where the fuck am I?
I was here!
The chest is open!
Oh, I ran near his back here?
Is it that?
Oh, I didn't gather lily pads.
Alright.
Am I heading west?
Is this- is this west?
One day, I'll find my journey to the west.
One day, the journey- the journey to the west will be over.
Is it here?
Journey to the well.
Getting warmer?
What's that sound?
Does it jump up?
Where the fuck is this goddamn well?
How the fuck do I get there?
I can't enter again!
Wait!
Oh my god, that's yellow- No, I can't!
The hole?!
When there's a hole, there's a goal, but where the fuck is this hole you speak of?
Look behind me?
Oh my god.
That's a hole.
But I can't get in.
But- I can't even get in the hole!
It doesn't even let- Where's the child?
I didn't find the ghost kid?!
Did not find the coughing baby?!
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Go to Wind Rest, where the three assassin rats attack you, then come- Where the fuck is that?!
Where-
Okay.
Alright.
Where am- Where am I?
Where's the incense?
Oh my god.
I can't.
I'm so lost.
Bro, I can't deal with you, bro.
I'm trying to figure out how to get out of here.
Oh my god.
Alright.
We missed.
Alright, we gotta find the- We gotta find another fast travel.
No, I'm not gonna use the item in my bag.
What if I need it later, guys?
Guys, what if I need it la- Guys, you don't understand.
What if I need it later?
It's infinite uses.
Guys,
no.
What if I- Guys, you don't understand.
It might be important later.
I'm saving it for Wukong 2.
Okay, travel.
We're not to go again?
Is it this amulet?
Is this?
Is this one?
Alright.
The natural gamer response.
What if, like, Wukong 2 takes your inventory from last game, guys?
What if your progress travels What if your progress, you know, What if your progress, you know, What if your progress, you know, passes over?
What if your progress, you know, passes over?
Wrong!
Okay, wrong.
A little horse guy.
I'm- Whoa, whoa!
I have enough stamina in the world!
Alright, back I go.
Let's see.
I mean, I'm pretty sure- I'm actually looking forward to see what this game company's gonna make in the future for gaming.
I mean, they've been- This as their first game is actually crazy.
Like, as their first fucking game.
Okay, child.
Where the fuck are you?
Where are the children?
Left?
Oh.
Oh, no, that's Gat Ingredients.
Oh!
Coughing baby!
Little monkey, I'm here.
I'm here.
Ratta?
Also, why am I holding a child's toy in my inventory?
Like, I'm a little-
Where's my dad?
Wait,
what?
You're - Wait, your dad might be a bad person!
What do you mean?
What do you mean you- Did your dad feed you to the other monsters?
That's fucked.
Alright.
Don't worry, I'm not gonna use any of my magic.
Boop!
Because you're pretty weak.
Oh, shit.
Alright.
We found the other baby.
We found the other coughing baby.
Now, can I go back to the well?
Okay.
Now it's well time.
Alright.
It's so fucking well time.
Oh my god.
Holy shit, it's well time.
Oh, thank god.
I think if I didn't- If I was not a streamer, and I had to do this all by myself, I think we would- This game will not be finished.
This will not be finished, but like, I would definitely not have done the side quest because I would not have known what to do.
I would not have known what to do for the side quest.
I got that.
This would definitely take me a lot longer to finish, that's for sure.
If I didn't have chat telling me where to go.
I'm always lost.
Nice.
Goodbye.
Here we go.
Thanks for the will, sucker.
Okay.
Time to go to the well.
Oh.
Child?
Come out, child.
Ghost?
Are you guys summoning a fucking monster?
I don't know.
My grandpa told me not to jump into strange wells with ghosts who told me there's a friend living down there.
Oh, it could be a Ninja Turtle though.
Oh my god.
Am I gonna meet the Ninja Turtles?
Guys, I don't think...
Guys, I don't think that's a Ninja Turtle.
Guys, I don't think that's a Ninja Turtle, guys.
Guys, I don't... Guys, I think the kid baited me.
Guys, I think the kid baited me!
Holy shit!
A child baited... I knew it!
Instead of the bed, the child baited me into the well!
That's so fun.
Oh my god.
The child baited me.
Oh shit.
Oh!
These monkeys!
What?!
The tiger is...
destroying my frames!
Holy shit!
The tiger is so mad that my frames just died!
That is a very mad tiger.
Oh my god.
The tiger is so mad.
I couldn't see where I was.
Where am I?
Oh my god.
Monkey children, go!
Go, monkey children, go!
Oh!
Jesus Christ!
Oh, he's so mad!
Oh!
What is this moose?!
Holy shit!
Oh, you need the lower effects?
Oh my god!
There's too many particles!
There's so many particles!
Oh my god.
Why did you bring me into the well, child?
Oh, child, please!
Oh my god.
This is so scary.
Hair!
Oh!
No!
No hair.
Oh, yes, there is hair!
What is going on?
What?
There is so many!
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
What?
What is this boss fight?
Nobody is back!
Oh my god, he's talking out!
He walked out!
Why didn't I listen to the giant?!
Oh my god.
I'm lowering the effects.
I can't.
I need to lower the effects in this one arena.
It's actually crazy.
I cannot see anything.
The frames are so...
I hate it when a child lures me into a well.
Oh my god.
What do I have to lower?
What is it?
There's so many things!
Is it the effects?
Is it the post-effect quality?
Or the visual?
Is it the visual effects?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Low.
Alright.
Yes.
Okay, this might help me.
This might actually help.
It's just for the tiger.
Oh my god, look at his hair!
Look at his hair!
Holy shit.
Where am I?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Do you think the baby can smash him there?
Baby still smash!
Okay, I need to like go drink some hydrate real fast.
Oh no.
It's definitely a lot better though.
Not gonna lie.
It feels so much better.
Oh my.
I can actually see.
Is that crazy?
Oh.
Oh shit!
Oh my god!
Please don't grab me!
I'm just a little monkey!
Oh!
Oh my god!
He's so fucking strong!
I couldn't heal!
Oh my god.
Wolf.
Wolf guy is my only hope.
I'll hit...
No!
Like I said that and then I missed.
And I missed again.
And I'll keep missing.
That's fucking right.
Alright.
No, I didn't mean...
Oh, I did not mean to...
No!
No, you fucking...
Come on.
Get the hairs.
Get the hairs in.
Get the hairs in!
Oh my god.
Come on.
You gotta get over here, right?
No!
Jesus!
Oh!
This is so much!
I'm so sorry!
Alright.
JK, I was never...
Oh shit!
I'm sorry!
I'm so sorry!
I'm...
Okay.
Oh!
Fuck it!
Can you remember that he does that?
Okay.
It's okay.
He's too busy for that.
I'm relaxing now.
Oh!
Okay.
Nice!
PUSH!
OH!
FUCK!
Why did I POK!
I should have known poking was a mistake!
No!
Okay.
I
couldn't dodge it in time!
I couldn't dodge it in time!
Okay.
Jesus Christ!
Stupid tiger!
I thought it was over!
I didn't think I had the team.
I didn't realize totally the tiger had a fucking brother!
Oh my god.
Okay.
Head bash!
Here!
Okay.
Not okay.
I do not feel okay right now.
His abilities.
Tony and the tiger and his brother Frank the Tank.
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ.
He's so fucking strong.
No.
Wait, did I even hit him?
No, I don't think I did.
Okay.
Smash!
Here.
Oh god.
Smash!
Smash to the sequel!
Okay.
Oh my god.
Are you fucking kidding me?
I like how the monkey's healing too.
Oh shit.
Where did my monkey's go?
Go!
Monkey!
Okay.
Oh, please!
Have mercy on me!
I didn't know!
No, I missed!
I'm gonna make it last.
Why?
Why did I follow the child into the well?
What?
I thought it was a good idea!
Oh no!
It's hog time!
Goodbye!
Guys, never follow a child into a well.
Never, never follow...
I thought he was gonna give me treasures!
They were right.
Children are evil.
Okay, this time... oh wait, there's an incense.
Is there?
I never noticed this.
I never noticed it.
Alright.
Kids are so cruel.
They are.
Okay.
Well, where am I?
Oh my god, I was like, I couldn't even see where I am.
Pew!
Alright.
Bash!
I'm gonna do it out of order.
And then... hair.
Now I should have time.
Okay, here we go.
Oh!
No, I timed incorrectly!
I sometimes don't know which is that move!
It's so fucking infuriating!
Oh my god!
It's so hard to predict!
Okay.
Oh my god, that's not it!
That's not it, guys!
Oh my god!
I
can't believe I got baited by you guys!
Side quest!
That's the high... the child... the coughing baby.
This is literally... that's the hydrogen bomb right there.
He is the hydrogen bomb.
He was the hydrogen bomb this whole time.
Alright.
Boom!
Oh, okay.
Baby!
Okay.
Alright.
Hair!
Hair time.
Fucking hell!
Oh, okay.
Alright, we're just gonna...
Okay.
Alright.
I dodged it once.
That's all I could do!
Oh, you can run too?!
I closed count.
Oh, it's so bad.
Oh, I'm still trying to figure out...
It's like his move sense is so weird.
I'm still trying to figure out...
I think the hardest part is that his movesets are so fucking weird that I can barely register what they are sometimes.
Some people say I should just save.
Jesus!
Okay.
God damn it!
Oh my god.
No, please!
No, no, no, no, no, no!
Okay.
Please, hydrate.
Hydrate!
No!
He slammed me!
Dodge.
Drink.
Hydrate time!
Dodge!
I'm
gonna poke you in the ass!
Hydrate.
I'm sorry.
I know you didn't like that.
Oh, okay.
Butt time!
Okay.
No!
The giant butt slam!
Oh...
Alright.
No, no!
No!
I don't...
Guys, I don't know.
I don't know that.
Oh, god!
We
got the Tire!
Fucking hate children.
I need a rest.
Oh, holy shit.
Okay.
Who's stronger?
The baby or the tiger?
Takes the form of void or pteromite, shocks surrounding foes and deals aria damage to the front.
But massively reduces maximum health.
I feel like it's still not as good.
I feel like...
Oh, but lowers health?
Yeah, no.
Alright.
Then we don't do it.
Baby better.
The ugly tiger.
Okay, the baby is still better.
Why is the baby always better?
There would be some good-ass treasure.
You're fucking baiting me into the well.
What?
How concord is that?
That's fucking...
Oh no.
Is it worth it?
Health recovery is half, but attack is increased.
You know what?
You're right.
Ungabunga.
Wait, and the child never talks to me?
He literally baited me into the fucking well.
And then disappears.
And then fucking disappears.
I fucking hate children.
He actually disappears.
Oh my god.
What an epic...
Oh my god, what an epic prank.
What a fucking troll.
Oh my god, Kappa's baby actually baited me.
Oh my god.
Where is the seller?
That's what I call a pro ghost move.
The child who cried tiger.
He got his TikTok video.
He's like, I'm out.
Got my video.
Hey, what's this then?
Where's this go?
Yellow wind formation.
You salvaged his soul and he moved on to the afterlife.
Very good.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Where am I?
Oh, I don't know if I'm supposed to be here.
I just...
I just got out of a boss fight.
I...
This is mine.
I just got out of a boss fight.
I took you away, need your help.
I was trying to get you extend...
He took out your couch.
Oh, Jack, I knew this would happen.
Now we're up against a guy who I'm in.
You're out now.
Here we go.
I just got here.
Oh my god, please.
Holy shit.
Is it even worth fighting him?
He has to be optional.
Another boss fight.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
He has to be optional.
He had a cutscene.
He's the last boss of chat.
How did I get here?
How the fuck did I get here?
He's apparently the last boss.
Oh, that's the door.
Wait, is that the door I opened earlier?
No, that's not...
Oh, that's the door.
Okay, I found...
Guys, I found where the door was supposed to go.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Life is actually a cruel joke.
There must be something in the back.
There has to be something back here.
Okay, what's the quest?
Is it this guy?
Hello.
Oh, it's time to meditate.
I hate children.
Today I... dear diary.
Today I got baited into the well.
He said he had... there was some cool stuff in there.
I knew it when they said stranger danger.
They meant stranger danger.
Never follow children under... to wells.
It's never a good idea.
Even if they promised Ninja Turtles.
Meditation over.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Don't follow strange children into wells, guys.
That's my life lesson for you today.
I'll grab health too.
Like, I fucking need this at this point.
I'll get mana.
Let's see.
Is this the quest?
Oh!
Oh, that's it?
One step.
A match game?
One guy by child.
Couldn't beat me... your diary.
Today I got one guy by a child.
Have I truly hit rock bottom?
I just remembered, I need to turn back my settings for that area.
Alright.
T.
I think playing on mouse and keyboard is definitely a lot easier for me.
I'm glad I played it on MNK instead of controller.
These are life lessons I will take going forward.
Alright.
Did you swap the jump button?
No, I'm using controller.
I feel like jump is only used for exploring IMO.
I'm trying to find... Okay, we gotta go to that rock.
Okay.
What's wrong with her?
I fucking killed two tigers today!
All with MNK!
That's called being a fucking gamer.
Alright, let's see.
What is it called?
What is that rock place called, chat?
Dargoons?
What was it called?
You wanted to be a Y-mom so it does let you experience a child tricking you into Tony the Tiger.
How thoughtful.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That was not Tony the Tiger.
That was Frank the Tank.
Raw Clash.
I guess it's the Buddha eyes, right?
Like, I have to find six Buddha eyes.
Oh, hey.
No, that's where I was.
What am I doing?
Here we go.
This is where I...
This is...
This was always like this.
There was no rock monster here.
There never was the rock monsters here.
Alright, where do I go?
Okay, we gotta get rid of this guy.
This guy fucked me up last time.
I don't care.
I will fuck him up this time.
That's right.
That's right!
Boom!
You ain't gonna fuck me up this time.
I learned my lesson.
Yeah.
There was never...
Who said rock monsters?
There was never any rock whatever.
Oh!
Yeah!
Oh, that's a lot.
That's a lot of archers.
Spooky archers.
Wrong way.
Where am I going?
Okay, I might be going the wrong way, but there's loot.
Guys.
No way is the wrong way when there's loot.
Guys, it's never the wrong way.
I didn't go the wrong way.
I just wanted loot.
I didn't explore this cave yet.
Where the fuck is this place?
What?
What the fuck?
Okay, I did not expect that.
Holy shit.
That actually scared the shit out of me.
Oh, my God.
Like, where did he come from?
No, I'm getting poisoned!
This is stupid!
OPEN!
Oh god.
AND MY ATTACK'S STILL NOT GOOD ENOUGH!
Oh my god, there we go.
Oh my god, does these guys remind me of the Silent Hill?
JESUS CHRIST!
Oh my god, he's kicking me!
He's kicking me!
That's why he's so strong!
Holy shit, I have no more heals.
Thank god I have heals.
I was gonna say I have no more heals after that.
What is in here?
Hello?
Oh?
Oh!
Guys, I don't think I like that.
Mother of Stones?
Does that mean...
OH!
Guys...
Guys, I don't think... I don't think I like that.
Okay, I don't like this gourd.
I don't like this gourd.
Bring me back.
Bring me back to a healed gourd.
Hair.
Oh, it interrupted my hair!
No.
Okay.
He's down.
Don't tell me they respawn.
Right?
Is this what Mother of Stone does?
No?
Okay.
It's over for you.
It's fucking...
OVER!
Fuck!
It's not over!
Who would've thought?
Oh, no!
I was like...
What if, like, he doesn't respawn?
You know?
Wouldn't that be funny?
Alright, let's get rid of him first.
Alright.
I'm back.
I'm back for more.
That's fucking right.
Oh, shit.
He doesn't like that.
Oh, fuck!
There's two!
He definitely did not like that.
Boom!
That's fucking right.
Well, keep going.
I didn't learn my lesson yet.
What the fuck?
You almost got me.
Oh, gosh.
Where's the other guy?
Oh!
Oh, shit!
Come on.
Poke!
I'm back.
I'm still gonna be here.
That's right.
You haven't lost me yet!
That's fucking right!
I'm back!
I'm back, baby!
Yeah!
That's right.
I even kill mothers in-game.
Oh, shit.
Yeah!
Will anybody stop her?
Now, no one will ever need to pay for child support.
I did it.
Wukong is not a bad person.
No.
Now, no one will have to pay child support.
Wait.
I can...
Is there, like, actually...
I can climb up?
There's no way.
Oh, my God.
Is that, like...
Wukong did nothing wrong.
The head outside?
What?
There's a head?
Oh, there it is.
There's the head.
Yoink.
My eye now.
Yeah!
Nice.
We got another Buddha eye.
Four more to go.
That wasn't so bad.
Ever since the tiger incident.
Ever since I got one kid.
Things got a lot easier.
I learned my lesson.
I told myself never to get one kid again.
Jesus Christ.
I hate these guys, actually.
Like, I'm tempted to literally just turn into the wolf guy just to get these guys out of my game.
Oh, he's dead.
Nice.
All right.
Wait.
There's another cave.
Where does this cave lead?
I don't know.
There's another cave.
Where does this cave go?
Oh.
Oh, I'm a little worried.
I don't know where I am.
I'm worried I don't know where I am.
Oh, there's another eye!
Okay.
I had to.
I was so scared.
I didn't know what he was going to do to me.
Oh, you're just going to die.
Hey, give me the eye!
There's... Oh!
You fucker!
You try to be sneaky!
I was like, why can't I pick up the eye?
Alright.
Nice.
Now that I got the Buddha eye, it's time to...
It's time to beat up everything around it.
Alright, that's another eye.
Woah!
Big boy!
Now you're an orphan.
Don't have a mom now.
Baby can help you access two secret bosses?
Which baby?
There's so many... I killed...
You gotta be very specific on which baby it is.
Alright, nice.
Oh!
You can access secret bosses?
That's interesting.
Let's get closer.
Oh shit!
Guys, I'm very lost.
There's a lot of passageways.
The secret is that I'm always lost.
But like, now I'm exceptionally lost.
Oh!
God dammit!
That's right.
I cannot... These mimics are so fucking tanky.
I cannot be bothered to fight them normally.
They're way too tanky.
What?
How do I get up there?
There's too many.
There's...
Oh my god!
Are you fucking kidding me?
How do I get up there?
I actually can... Oh wait!
There's a ton of them.
I'm gonna get you.
Oh.
Yeah, I'm getting good XP, which is nice.
I just always don't know what to upgrade with the XP, you know?
Was that it?
Oh, it was just a secret tunnel.
Secret tunnel!
I'll go this way.
Oh, nice!
There's an incense.
The buff rat?
Which one?
Guys.
There's a lot of very buff rats.
I'll never know which is the right rat.
I'll never know which is the right Poke!
Ow!
I tipped him over.
It's like tipping a cow.
I should be able to grab this now.
Yay!
The last...
Which one?
You gotta be more specific.
Guys, you gotta be very specific on the buff rats.
Poke!
Oh, god.
Where am I?
All I'm doing is gathering eyes, but...
What is he guarding?
Have I been here before?
Poke!
Why'd you miss?
Loser.
You killed a baby.
Do you have any idea how little that narrows it down?
Thank you for the super chat, Gary.
Thank you.
Oh, this was the...
This was the main area.
Sorry, I went the...
I went the secret entrance.
This was how... This was the one where you guys were like, No, the other way!
And I was like, huh?
But there's cave.
Guys, I found the other way.
I found the actual area I was supposed to go.
Oh, but there's a bridge.
I've never seen this bridge before.
But cave though!
Exactly!
Cave!
Where am I?
Where the fuck am I?
What is this place?
Oh, hey!
What's this?
Is this where I killed the first big buff rat?
Oh, is this where I killed the dad?
Oh!
No, the son!
The son!
The son with like, head issues.
Now where am I?
The where am I game.
What is this?
Wait, I got the shortcut!
Oh, I unlocked the shortcut!
What the fuck is the point of shortcuts when I have fast travel?
Time to break the wall?
Where wall?
This wall?
Guys, there's not...
There's a lot of walls.
Guys, there's a lot of walls.
You have to be very specific.
On the wall.
Here?
Here.
Now which wall?
That wall.
Is it this wall?
Oh shit, nice.
Drop down.
Okay.
Wall.
Purple.
That's a wall.
That wall.
This wall?
Buddha wall.
There's a wall with the Buddha?
Oh, that is the wall!
God, I'm so smart.
You guys want to watch me die really fast?
Oh, okay.
In I go.
See?
In one day, people have already found the baby wall!
In just one day!
Vacciners have already found the baby wall!
Look at what one day can give us!
Oh, this is not...
I think you guys took me to a boss fight.
I think you guys took... Oh, hey.
Oh, this is just treasure.
Oh, thank god.
It's just loot.
What did I get?
...
Oh, it's a secret boss key?
What was the point?!
Guys, I don't think I will be doing any...
I don't know if I'll be doing any secret bosses.
All right, I already lost track of where... oh we were trying to find buddha eyes.
I was like, what was my main mission again?
We've taken so many detours.
We already forgot what the main mission was.
We have to find buddha eyes.
That was the main... oh no, where was the entrance again?
It was... was it this way?
Where?
Oh no.
No, it was up here.
It was up here.
And then it was up here.
All right.
Where am I?
Was it west?
Where was I headed?
West, right?
We're heading west.
Okay.
Um, and then from here, I came from this way.
This is where I came from.
I'm still running.
I'll never stop running.
I'm running.
Where are you?
Where are you trying to run to?
Don't hear from my demons.
I need to run.
If I stop, if I stop, they'll get me.
Wait, where's this?
Where am I?
What?
Have I been here before?
What the fuck am I?
Oh, this is the... this is the frog.
THIS IS THE FROG.
I fucking hate sad Ladd.
Bro.
Oh my god I swear.
The sad.
No, I have to go back to the booth!
Oh hey,
I gathered.
Guys, if I wasn't lost, I wouldn't be able to gather this.
Guys, this was actually Sandland Part 9.
Where am I?
Where is this place?
Oh, I found... Oh, meditation!
Where am I?
Is this the... This is Wendy's?
We're still on Chapter 2.
We found... We found... Hey, we found this!
Holy shit!
We're still here?!
Oh my god!
Oh, we're still here!
Oh my god.
I feel like...
How do I fast travel to the nearest shrine?!
How do I do that?!
I don't know, I'm stupid.
Oh my god, I'm gonna use this.
Fuck this.
I'm sorry, Wukong 2.
Oh shit, instant transmission!
Oh my god, I made it.
Where is... Where am I?
Actually, where am I?
Where is this place?
I don't remember if they all look the same!
Everything looks the same!
I can't tell!
Where did I go?!
Where have I...
Oh, please!
You're not important enough to me!
Where is more Buddha?
Whoa!
Hello, sir!
I'm still lost!
It didn't help!
The sad part is that I'm still just as lost.
Like, I feel like...
I feel like I did not get better.
I...
Oh no, please!
Fuck this.
I can't.
Your baby time.
I will fucking bring out...
I've been lost for too...
I've been traveling for too long!
Oh hey, there's a chest though!
I can't.
I've been traveling for too long!
Alright, mine core.
Because I'm a super freak.
Guys, that wasn't...
Guys, I did not go the right way.
Maybe it's...
This way?
Where...
Where is the Buddha?
Where the fuck are the Buddha eyes?
There it is!
I see one!
Oh, what the...
Who fucking...
Who hit me?
Who threw a rock at me?
Who is that?
Who threw the rock?
Show yourself!
Oh!
Show yourself right now!
You think you can hide from me?
I learned how to jump!
Wait, maybe...
That's fucking right!
There's stairs!
I could have used the stairs!
God damn it!
Oh, come here!
Wait, who told me to come over?
Who said that?
Someone was like, come here, come here!
Mom told me not to trust strangers after what...
After I encountered Frank the Tank.
Another child.
I will not get one kid again.
I will never trust another...
Another stranger after the kid incident.
See, I missed the chest here.
Nice!
Got gold!
Oh, the last Buddha head is right over here.
Oh, there he is!
I'm gonna grab the last Buddha head first.
Yoink!
Got your eyes!
So who told me to come over?
You heard that guy, right?
He's like, come here, come here!
Where is that from?
Down the water?
Alright.
What, he just...
Okay.
Yeah?
Oh!
What the...
I am trapped in the stone?
Even the stone on the head has been transformed into a crystal.
I have been surprised by a stone crystal in that cave.
It must contain some secrets.
After all the things I have done, I can now get to mu!
Oh...
Stone transformed into a crystal...
The cause is something else.
Wait, is that that mother stone?
Yeah, didn't I kill it?
Oh shit!
It was alive?
That's fucking right.
You think I'm scared of you?
Fire can burn rock!
Oh my god, I forgot I already used the baby.
I don't know what to do.
I'll just keep burning the rock eventually!
Stranger danger.
I fucking knew it.
Never trust strangers.
Every fucking time.
I thought today would be different.
It's never different!
Wait,
what is this?
Mimic?
Wait, did I got like the...
Imagine Stone.
But what can I use?
I can't invade other people's lands.
I can't invade the Wukong multiverse.
I can't
invade the Wukong multiverse.
Where is it anyway?
This one?
Oh, he's a wolf transformation.
Oh, I see.
How do I change it then?
Actually, I don't know what to level up.
I'll grab defense too then.
Uh...
Oh, is it the stride?
Okay.
I still don't know if I wanna...
If I wanna use that or...
What is better?
The wolf or the rock?
I don't even know what the rock does.
I'm not gonna lie.
Uh...
A buckle?
But there's two ups.
Which is the right...
Oh, this is chest up.
Oh, nice.
So...
Haha, yoink!
Took your treasure!
Okay.
Oh, I'm not gonna make it.
Oh god, that's awkward.
Haha.
Whoops.
It's okay.
I need to recharge my stamina.
Don't worry, I got this.
Poke your butt!
Come on.
Come on, let me poke your butt one last time!
Come on!
Just a simple poke!
God damn it, your shield is so strong!
Poke!
Nice.
Okay, he's dead.
Is this where I got the first Buddha?
Oh yeah, this is the original rock area.
Oh...
Is it here?
What is this?
Okay, that's nothing.
Where am I?
Where will I ever go?
Shield user derogatory...
Oh my god, where did he come from?!
Oh, to the boss!
Oh!
I can go to the... back to the rock?
To the area where there was like... nothing there?
That wasn't a boss area.
What are you talking about?
Oh, go up those stairs?
What stairs?
There were stairs?
This?
There's so many stairs.
Oh!
What you gonna do?
Hit me?
Oh wait, I can't even hit you.
Ow!
Please!
Please stop saying your poetry right now!
I'm trying to kill a guy!
Please!
I can't stop your poetry!
I have to kill something!
Hello.
Oh.
Oh no.
Wait a minute.
He still has his shield.
Big baby!
That's fucking right.
You're nothing without your shield!
Easy.
Poetry important.
He can't lure right now!
I'm at the line that's busy!
I'm trying to fucking...
I'm trying to fucking kill the people!
Alright.
Did not go.
I parted the sand.
Door open!
What's in the cave?
What is this?
Why is there a cave within the cave?
Oh no!
Black loan?
Black dragon?
Wait...
Wait a minute.
I'm sorry for not listening to your poetry!
Poetry.
Oh my god.
I'm sorry I didn't listen to your poetry.
It was a very nice poem.
I'm sorry.
I'll listen to your poetry next time.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
Oh the music slaps though.
Not gonna lie.
And that's not the only thing that's slapping me.
Jesus Christ.
Please I'm sorry.
Oh god.
Okay.
Oh.
Managed to do electricity too.
That's good.
That's so good.
Oh what?
We actually have to jump?
Jumping isn't a botanical now?
Hey guys.
Thank god I learned how to jump.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
I can't...
Can't paint it yet again.
Why does this keep happening to me?
Why...
Why do I keep getting painted into boss fights?
Oh my god.
It's never something...
It's never...
it's never something happy.
It's always a boss fight.
Oh god.
I thought it'd be treasure.
I don't know.
I thought I'd get some cool ass treasure.
It'd be some new equipment.
Boom!
Oh, is he gonna... what's he doing?
Boom.
Okay.
There's a rock?
Me?
Oh post, that's what you're right.
Oh, wait.
Alright.
You're right.
I forgot I have more on stands.
Wait, I could stand on a rock.
I could stand on this rock.
Wait, you're right.
What the fuck?
Why am I... I could just...
Oh, shit.
No!
Baby!
What?
Poke?
What the fuck?
What is this?
Oh
my god.
That's new.
Yeah.
Okay.
That was new.
Oh god.
Oh, boom.
Okay.
This has to be Rock Tab.
That's right.
What you gonna do now?
I'm on a rock!
Can't do nothing I'm gonna hydrate too.
Bum, bumb.
Bum, bumb!
I didn't realize there was one more.
He had one more in him.
That was very awkward.
He got me there.
He actually got me there.
There was one more secret move.
Oh, God.
This is not fair.
No, my rock.
Oh, God.
No, what am I going to do?
I don't have my rock.
Okay.
All right.
That was sick.
That was not intentional, by the way.
Oh, no.
That jump was definitely not intentional.
Intentional did not mean to do that.
But I'll take it.
Boom.
Okay.
Bye.
Oh, my God.
This guy is so difficult.
I'll do one more hydrate.
Can I get him this rock?
Oh, no.
No.
Okay.
I get it now.
I timed it.
All right.
I figured it out.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Wolf out.
No.
Oh, I'm dead, though.
I'm dead.
I don't have enough heals for this.
Boop.
Okay.
No.
I couldn't clutch.
It's time to kick.
I figured out the rhythm pattern, though.
I don't need the rock anymore.
Oh, my God.
I know how to do the mechanic now.
Jeez.
Okay.
Full focus.
We're gonna beat this dragon.
I love the music, though.
The music is so sick.
Holy shit.
Okay.
One more swing.
Big baby.
And then...
Boom.
Okay.
All right.
Come on.
Oh, no.
This one I don't like.
I don't like this move.
Okay.
Nice.
I just dodged it.
Oh.
Okay.
That's right.
Big poke!
All right.
I think it's time.
Is it time?
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
That's not great.
All right.
Nice.
Oh.
I have to go full focus on that.
No!
Okay.
Nice.
I dodged it.
Oh.
Full focus.
No!
Drink.
Hi, drink!
Come on.
No!
What?
I've never seen that move before!
That's fucked!
Okay.
Oh, my God.
I've actually never seen that move before!
It's not fair.
He's cheating.
No!
I jumped the wrong one.
Okay.
Oh, no.
No!
Fuck!
I fucked that up.
That was the wrong pattern.
Oh.
I always forget the pattern sometimes.
Oh, no.
No, no, no, no.
Oh, this is my last heal.
Oh, that's not my last heal.
Thank God.
Okay.
No!
What?
Oh.
Sometimes I don't know why he does that.
No.
Okay.
Fine!
Wolf time.
Wolf.
Let me at least have one more wolf!
I really appreciate it!
Thank you for letting me have the wolf!
Oh, no.
Yes!
Oh, my God.
I tried to lock it!
I had to lock it.
I actually had to time everything.
Oh, my God.
Oh.
That shit is so...
Oh, my God.
This game is so difficult.
Oh, we did it!
We got the thunderbolt!
What the fuck is the thunderbolt?
We got a pendant too!
Oh my god.
That was...
Oh, that is giving me a victory bark.
You hear somebody outside, so he's like, Dad is celebrating!
What the fuck do my items do anyway?
Oh, I can't believe it.
He's dead.
He's fucking dead.
Oh my god.
I thought he was a nice guy!
He was saying poetry!
The other is staff material?
Okay.
When is it equipable?
Is it these?
Oh, it's these!
Reduces cooldown of spells.
Wait, I like that.
What do I have?
I have stamina.
And increases...
Ah!
I feel like critical hit chance is more important.
I'm gonna grab the cooldown.
Yeah, I don't...
I'll grab the cooldown and the critical hit chan...
Uh, the hit chance.
Okay.
Now I gotta figure out how to get back.
Oh, there it is.
Got back, guys.
Figured it out.
Alright.
Buddha time.
Yeah.
I got the six eyes.
Now be free.
Is this good rope?
Is this good rock?
Friend?
Oh, please tell me this is friend.
Please, please.
Friend?
Oh, it's not friend!
Okay.
Alright, here we go again!
Here we go again!
Whoa!
Hello, not friend.
He's not friend.
Guys, he was not friend.
He was not.
No!
God, okay.
Now we know.
Now we know at least.
I can't believe it wasn't a friend.
No!
I can't get that timing correct.
Okay.
Oh my god, he's slamming.
When will they be friends?
Why can't we be friends?
Why are they all...
Why do they all hate me?
I'm not even the real Xu Meng!
I'm not even him!
He's in the wrong!
Okay.
Nice.
Oh.
Oh god.
Okay.
You look like him and that's all that.
That's just cause I'm a monkey!
Do I say all rocks look like him?
No, I don't!
Just cause I'm a monkey?
That's fucked.
Okay.
Oh god, not okay.
Oh, definitely not okay.
Oh, come on!
Just get hit by everything.
Oh no.
Okay.
Are you fucking serious?
Oh shit!
No!
I can't get the timing correct!
Oh my god!
He's like, I don't know his combos!
Dad's just watching me from outside!
He's judging me!
He's...
He's judging me from outside right now!
I'm sorry!
Oh my god, I just gotta...
I have to go find another boss right after!
Okay, skip.
Oh...
Okay.
Oh no, I forgot to lock it in.
Oh...
Oh!
Okay.
Freeze.
Boom!
Okay.
Ah!
God damn it!
Oh no, this is not good!
I'm gonna smack that butt!
Just like how I smacked your mom's butt!
Oh shit!
...
Oh my god.
Alright, nice, nice.
He just jumps, so I don't have to worry about that!
And then smack!
And I get hit?!
I see you got...
I see you got your butt from your mom!
Okay, we just dodged that.
No!
That timing is so weird!
It's such a weird timing for like the floor!
I could never like figure it out!
...
Okay.
Nice.
Oh!
I got the dodge just in time!
The sky dodge!
Boom!
Oh shit, he sat on me!
Oh my god!
Come on, come on!
Smack!
Okay, and then dodge!
Okay, I need to redo my stamina!
I need to redo my stamina!
I'm not intentionally aiming for the butt!
It's just there!
Look, it's not my fault!
My staff fits the...
My staff fits it perfectly!
It's just...
My staff just fits it perfectly into the instance!
You know?!
...
Nice.
Oh!
Now there's definite...
Now they will never find the ponies for real!
Oh my god, we did it!
Was that the side quest?
What do I do with that?
Now what do I do with that?
Whatever you say, Doki!
Oh, I can grab weapons!
Wait, does that mean...
70...
60...
Wait, but this is 70!
Refined Iron Staff.
Oh, but I don't have enough.
I guess I have to do this then.
Alright.
I guess I'll get that?
Modern increase the damage executed by charged smash...
Charged smash heavy attacks.
Um...
Okay.
Do I have anything else to craft?
No, right?
Okay.
We want that...
Guys, let's finish chapter 2 first.
Guys!
Let's finish chapter 2 first!
Chat!
I just want to finish chapter 2 first.
Let's see.
Do I have enough for baby?
No, baby still...
No, no baby.
Okay, rock fist flat.
Here we go.
Guys, I just want to finish this chapter.
Guys, it's been 5 hours.
I've been...
I've been non-stop pause rushing.
Back to back.
Alright, now where do I go?
Wait, where am I supposed to go?
Go to the right.
There's a gap in the rocks.
There's so many gaps.
The sage?
Where was the sage, dude?
Wait, who the fuck slapped me?
Oh, behind the shrine.
Okay.
Which shrine?
This one?
Oh my god, please.
I couldn't even look at my incense.
It just fucking slapped me.
Oh, there he is!
I've been here?
I can't remember.
Hello?
What the fuck is wrong with you?
You don't know what you're doing?
Oh, my god.
Is everyone still alive?
Still?
You got me.
I thought you were still alive.
Like you were still alive.
What?
What the fuck?
Wait, this is a different mission.
This is a di- This is a different mission!
This is a different side quest!
Smack his belly?
Is he gonna hit me?
No, I just not think I...
Alright.
Oh, there's some meditation.
There's meditation.
Let's meditate.
Manual chapter 2.
I don't like sand.
I don't like...
It's just...
It's too much sand.
It's just too much...
I'm not even gonna bother with this guy.
It's just too much sand.
I don't know what to do...
with all this sand!
Why can't I go through this?
When will the sand end in sand land?
Okay, Tiger Temple.
I like the bosses.
I'm just so lost.
I think, like, I definitely like chapter 1's.
I don't mind exploration.
But, like...
Oh my god!
Where am I?
Confucius says chapter 2 ends when chapter 3 begins.
Mori, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I like chapter 1.
Chapter 1 had...
Oh my god!
Did I go to the wrong place?
I can't tell!
Oh, there it is.
Stop!
Oh my god!
Okay.
I like chapter 1's map.
Chapter 2 map...
I...
I need a GPS.
There he goes on the right.
Oh, there he is!
There you are!
Oh, isn't that one that I got already?
Okay.
Now we go back.
Pig, why...
I finished the mission, Pig!
Just take my item!
Just...
I already finished the mission.
Just take it!
As I can take the item!
Okay.
Alright, where is it again?
I forgot where it was again.
Was it...
Oh...
Rockfest flat.
I'm curious on what he sounds like in English.
It's not about the item, it's about sending them.
Alright, what does he sound like?
I wonder what he sounds like in English actually.
The English voices are funny.
Wait, is this the right area?
Alright, here we go.
His English voice is pretty goofy.
Wait, he's not here!
Wait, where is he?
Oh shit.
No, he's gonna leave, right?
Alright, we'll see.
I wanna see what his English voice lines are.
Confirm.
I like how you can swap very easily though.
Is it to the right?
Huh?
Did I not feed him?
Did I not?
Fucker!
Oh my... you fucker.
You actual fucker.
How was I supposed to know he was done talking?
Like...
Oh my god.
I didn't know he wasn't done.
I talked to him twice.
And then he wants to talk a third time.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
He's so demanding.
He just wanted a friend.
He's a talkative guy.
Alright, we're gonna be able to hear him.
I just tried those rat guays.
They taste like men flesh.
It's people are not yet extinct.
I suspect the yellow wind guay had a role in that downfall.
Our senior brother gave me a piece of gold.
I'll need it here when the time is right.
Oh damn, he's bilingual?
It's the right time now.
I'm taking it to the right place.
Why are they always British?
Is he also from Hong Kong?
I just tried those rat guays.
Okay.
He's the Hong Kong pig.
Alright.
Now we go back.
We did it.
He learned another language while waiting for me.
Alright, here we go.
I don't know what language to play in.
I feel like both has its merits.
I guess Chinese for the immersion and stuff.
To be fair, a lot of what they're saying is very lore slash poetry heavy.
So it's like...
Where did you acquire my brother's gold piece?
Oh wait, you're not...
Oh shit!
Uh, pause!
Yeah, alright, I'll put it back in Chinese.
I feel like dialogue-wise, it doesn't really matter that much.
Dialogue-wise.
Because it's all very like...
There's like poetry and lore and everything.
So even when you're listening to it, you're like...
In English, it's like...
There's just rumbling some poetry.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright.
Oh shit.
Nice.
Alright.
I do...
I think that Chinese is definitely better voice acted.
100%.
I feel like.
Like in general.
Overall.
Because the dialogue was definitely...
Like, you know, the dialogue was heavily written for...
Ah!
Okay.
Oh, please.
Yeah, I definitely like the immersion.
Uh, the...
I like the voice acting.
Like overall, I do like the voice acting for the Chinese dialogue more than the English dub.
Come on.
Poke!
That's all?
Okay.
Damn.
That's right.
Poke!
Double poke!
Freeze!
And you should be dead.
Give me that gold!
Yeah, it's definitely a lot more immersive in Chinese.
Do I have to go inside now?
He opened the door just a little bit more so now I can fit!
Them tiny subs!
Oh my...
Guys, I even made the subtitles bigger for this!
Oh, but this is still...
This is still better though.
Yeah, I'm gonna keep this.
It's better still.
Oh my god.
This is...
Finally...
I'm sorry, dad!
Please!
I'm sorry!
Chapter two will end soon!
I promise!
What's going on?
Oh!
I'm sorry!
The phone was off!
The phone...
I'm sorry!
Please!
Where is Kang?
I let him in!
Please, I'm trying to get immersed!
He's inside now.
He wants to see the end of chapter two.
What?
Why does everyone think I'm him?
I'm not even actually him.
I just look like him.
He put on the Chinese subtitles.
Guys...
Why are you barking here?
Alright, incense time.
I swear to god, is this...
It's always Wooka.
It's always his fault.
I might be trying to bring him back, but is that too much to ask for?
You guys should have expected him to be brought back.
Who's that?
New area?
Alright guys, we're going to look at... I need to walk... I need to walk him.
I'll be right back.
Alright, you're going to listen to him.
I'm going to walk dad.
If this is a new area, I'll be back.
I'll be back in five minutes, guys.
We're going to listen.
I thought we... I thought it was going to be...
Walking... my dog.
Be right back.
I can't...
I'm going to be right back.
I don't know how much longer this is.
I'm going to go walk him.
I'll be right back.
A little
pause...
and we are back.
A little pause... and we are back.
A little
pause...
and we are back.
A
little pause... and we are back.
A little pause... and we are back.
A
little pause...
and we are back.
Are you guys okay?
Did you not enjoy the dialogue?
Over there.
Oh my god.
I'm back.
He's been a little shit.
So we bumped into another wiener dog.
So we bumped into another wiener dog, yeah.
And the thing is, he's been like super...
He's been like super territorial because we're at a new place.
So he's been more territorial than usual when he's leashed.
When he's leashed.
And then so...
There's a baby wiener dog.
There's like a baby wiener dog.
And the baby wiener dog...
Like we were at the lot.
The baby wiener dog does not know like what the fuck is going on.
Because he's still learning because he's a baby.
And so like the baby wiener dog like walked up to dad.
And you know, he's so happy because he's like...
Same, same, same, same dog, same dog.
And then dad was like...
Dad was like...
I was like, holy fuck.
He like tried to like run up to him.
He's like, get back up.
And then like...
The thing is, the smaller wiener dog, because he's a baby.
He's like...
Like basically...
Like basically one third dad's size.
And so he was like, is this how we play?
And then he...
So I was like pulling dad away.
I was pulling dad away.
It was like, no, no.
And then the baby wiener dog...
Tried to run back to my dog.
Because he thought it was play.
He thought...
He thought it was play.
He's like, is this how dogs play?
And he tried to...
And he was so happy too.
He was so fucking happy.
I was like, please no.
Don't get close.
I'll be like, I'm so sorry.
Oh my god.
I think it's because he's like...
He's still adjusting to his new environment.
So he's like not...
He's like so territorial with people.
Like with other dogs right now.
He's not like that before.
He's just like in the new environment.
When he's leashed.
It's only when he's leashed too.
Um.
Alright, here we go.
Is that dad?
Tiger Vanguard.
Am I gonna kill the dad?
Whoa.
What are my friends?
Who's this?
Is this Tony the Tiger's dad?
Who's dad is this?
New dialogue.
What is this new dialogue?
Oh yeah, you guys...
You guys are not used to that, are you?
You're like, wait.
I killed so many tigers.
I don't know which one this is.
Which tiger is this?
Jesus.
The frames is crazy though.
Like...
Oh.
Fuck.
Oh god.
Oh okay.
Oookay.
Settle down sir.
Settle down.
Oh my god.
His rapping is so long.
Oh god.
I can't.
Please.
What?
Oh.
That was scary.
No, he dodges that?
I didn't mean that, sir.
I was just joking.
Okay.
What?
Bro, he's so... What are these combos?
Oh my god.
What are these combos?
Oh my god, I don't have anything that's with it yet.
What are these fucking combos?
Also, I just noticed when I came back that my mic was a little lower than usual in the middle of this.
I hope that wasn't that noticeable.
I raised it back up to my usual audio.
Now?
Okay, that's good.
Good to know.
Oh god.
Here we go.
Is clone strong?
I can't... I normally don't use clones anymore because like everyone was telling me that it was like a waste.
I can't tell.
Everyone was like, oh yeah, it's better not to use your clones because it uses too much magic.
But I don't know.
I can't upgrade the... oh I should... wait, what the fuck?
I forgot.
I have to upgrade other stuff.
Guys, I forgot that like magic can be upgraded too.
Guys, did you guys know that?
That magic is awesome.
Wow!
I almost forgot about the magic upgrades.
Okay, nice.
Okay, oh god.
Okay, that's fine, that's fine.
That's fine!
Got you in the back!
Good combat!
I just realised I never upgraded my skills.
with me
What?
Are we friends now?
Are we friends?
Oh, we're friends now.
Okay.
Wait, why can't you join me?
Check humanity, return to pocket.
Thank you Super Chat, thank you, thank you!
Wait, is this the original Tony the Tiger?
Wait, is he the original before he went crazy?
Who is?
Oh!
Oh, he's the dad!
Bro, you have some crazy ass children.
Both of them!
What the fuck did you... Are you a bad dad?
Are you a bad dad?
Why are your kids crazy?
Why the fuck are you... What did you do to them?
Okay, we gotta grab the incense real fast.
What the fuck did he do to his kids?
To like, raise them up like that?
Alright.
Boop.
Alright, we gotta rest up.
We need to recharge.
This... Is this the longest chapter?
Out of all of it?
Let's see, make medicine store.
Okay, we gotta...
I think we have enough for skills.
Okay.
There you go, strand.
Okay, we need the damage.
And we definitely need this.
After using...
Hitting enemy's mana extends the dupe...
After using... Hitting enemy's mana extends the...
Oh!
Wait, that's so good!
Alright.
Okay, we gotta get that then.
Okay, alterations, cloud step.
Ahhhh...
Do we need any of the...
Immobilized?
Recover some mana to pop?
Wait, it recovers mana!
It's one of the shortest...
Oh, I'm doing the side quest...
So, it says it's one of the shortest.
I have just...
No way.
There's no way.
There's no way this is what the story is.
I don't... I'm in a new area.
Oh my god.
Okay, there's a chest.
Alright, we got not a voidness.
And we got a golden... oh, that open area does not look very promising.
This is also an open area.
Why is there...
Why is there so many open areas?
Why is there so...
Okay, this chest is open.
Where is this heading to?
Where are we heading to?
Oh, meditating.
Okay.
Alright.
Will we ever finish chapter 2?
It's been 50 years.
But yet we're still here.
Nobody ever realized that Wukong's chapter 2 was actually 55 years long.
No one has seen chapter 3 yet.
What does chapter 3 even look like?
I don't like how this is an open area.
This does not bring me joy.
Oh, no.
This does not bring me joy at all.
Oh my god.
Where am I supposed to go?
Was I not supposed to go into the middle of the sand?
NPC?
Oh shit, there he is.
Oops.
I somehow missed the giant ass NPC that is like the size of a fucking building.
Alright, don't worry.
I'm heading over.
I'm getting there.
Alright, here I come.
I don't know how I missed that.
Because chapter 2 was deroading my brain right now.
Oh no.
How do I get back up?
Wukong.
How do we get back up?
True Monk.
Are we stuck down here?
Guys, this is not looking so good.
Alright.
We're skateboarding.
We have to use the item.
Okay, here we go.
I hate monkey cat.
I'm sad too hard.
Oh my god.
Alright.
Here we go.
Hello, sir.
Oh, I'm not being a thrust.
Are you a turtle?
No, are you a giant rat?
What are you?
Are you a giant...
Oh.
Hmph.
I think you have some kind of magic power.
I don't know what magic power that monster has.
I'm not interested.
I can't even share it with the three of you.
I need to lure that monster out.
I need to use the Thunderbolt.
I can lure out the giant bug with my Thunderbolt.
Master Splinter?
Dune.
Yeah.
I was thinking that.
And then the Sadworm comes up.
Holy shit!
That's the giant-ass beetle.
Holy f- Digimon.
Digital monsters.
Ba-ba-ba champion.
digimon.
I see the digimon evolution.
Is that kabuterimon?
Oh my God, that's him!
We made it to the west!
H-day.
Oh, I have to kill him for him?
But aren't you also a Yaoguai?
What's wrong with this guy?
Why is this guy worse than your guy?
We're all guys here.
All right.
Okay.
Is he going to help?
Yeah, I can see that.
Oh, shit.
So, like, is he going to help me?
Is that not the claws?
Like...
Oh, this claw.
Oh, okay.
Wow.
Oh, hey.
Um...
So, is he going to...
Is he helping?
He said he was going to help, right?
Right?
All right.
Big baby.
I don't know.
I'm a little concerned at the lack of helping part here.
All right.
Nice.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Monkey.
Oh, no!
I couldn't use my monkey powers.
Okay.
I'm a little worried here.
He seems extra tanky.
I'm a little worried.
Is he just cheering me on?
He's not even going to help.
He's like, The weak points the claws.
Yeah, no shit.
It's the claws.
All right.
Now he goes back in.
He's just...
He's my backseater.
He's a dragoon.
He's in a backseat.
Let's fucking go.
All right.
What do I do?
He lied.
He lied!
He was like, Don't worry.
I'm going to help you.
I was like, Oh, shit.
Nice.
We were going to 2v1 him, right?
All right.
He told me to dodge.
That's all I needed.
He's not here.
He can't run.
What?
What happened?
Did I stub my toe?
Did I stub my toe in the fucking sand?
What the fuck?
Holy shit.
What the fuck was that?
He's the assistant.
Oh, thank you for helping me.
Thank you.
He's the vessel.
Here?
Where's the vessel?
Where is it?
Oh, there it is.
How the fuck do I get it?
What?
Sir, how do I get it?
That's the butt?
Oh, there it is.
How the fuck?
Oh, okay.
Okay, I figured it out.
Guys, surely he's going to keep sleeping, right?
Oh, my God.
Yoink.
You're my giant eye.
Yeah, the horn needed yellow paint, guys.
The horn.
Oh, my God.
Finally.
He's finally going to help.
Holy shit.
This is Godzilla vs King Kong right there.
Alright, nice.
Okay, that's not helping.
He still aims for me.
That's cool.
Alright, we both hit the arms.
We both do the thing.
Together.
Right?
Oh, my God.
He's actually helping.
That's fucking crazy.
Holy shit.
The kaiju battle.
There's some child-ass kaiju right there.
Oh, my God.
Go, Meese, go.
Take that, kaiju.
For all of me.
Okay, judging by the fact...
Wait, so, like, I made this happen.
Who's afraid of you?
It's not me.
Yeah, you're a fucking bug.
I'm just going to squish you.
I'm going to fucking squish your hand.
I like how I'm just hitting the hand.
Oh, man.
Oh, me.
Wait, so, I caused this.
We used to be friends.
What happened?
Oh, shit.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Holy fuck.
Why couldn't he do that earlier?
Why did he need us?
Exactly.
Why was I there?
Oh, my God.
And then we became best friends.
He needed a witness.
His vanguard couldn't watch him.
So, he needed me there.
I thought Q was the moral support.
But I was the moral support in the end.
That's actually crazy.
Abide by the Buddha's decree here to subdue the yellow wind guai.
Wind tamer?
How do I get that?
Oh, my God.
He needed a witness.
Witness me.
All right.
We need to...
Yeah, but he was on the floor for, like, a good five minutes.
He did not need me to...
Like, he could literally hit the drum, went downstairs, and got it.
Like, he did not need me to watch.
He literally...
He literally had it covered.
I, like, stood there confused because I was like, Where's the tip of this nose?
Like, where do I...
Where do I go?
Oh, no.
There it is.
All right.
We gotta...
He wanted...
He just wanted to...
All right.
Where do I have to travel here?
Is this...
No, that's the secret kingdom.
Where's the final boss?
Is it Windsteel Gate?
He wanted...
He needed witnesses so people can tell the tale.
He was thinking that I would write a story about what happened.
What?
Tiger Cellar?
Is this chapter...
Yes.
We're still there.
It's still chapter two.
Yes.
Yes, it is.
It has never stopped being chapter two.
Oh, cool.
I mean, that looks cool.
Yeah.
I wanna wear that.
Okay.
I do not have enough items.
That is not good.
Do I even have the...
Oh, I don't even have the additional damage anymore because I don't have the thing.
Oh...
Fuck it.
We're gonna keep doing it.
We're gonna keep it.
And then we gotta go to the Tiger Cellar yet again.
So my big rat friend literally went ham on this giant beetle.
Wait, where do we go?
After that.
Wait, is this not the Tiger Cellar?
Equip the vessel?
The vessel?
What's the...
Which one is the vessel?
Oh!
Okay.
Massively increases damage reduction for a short amount grants immunity highly effective against specific...
Oh!
Wait.
I'm gonna watch the demo.
That's...
Oh, that's sick.
Yeah, it counters the last boss.
Okay.
Uh...
Oops.
That's not what... Oh, no.
No, baby!
No!
It's okay.
We can rest.
We can fix it.
I can... I'll just rest.
Oh, and I can upgrade the baby!
Baby is strong!
Baby is even stronger now!
Thank God.
Oh, my God.
There was, like, something I saw that I could craft.
Oh, wait.
No, no.
Not crafting.
Um... It was...
I got too... Baby got too happy.
Alright.
Upon successful hits with...
Wait, what is it?
Upon successful hits with, like, combo mod or increased attack...
I feel like spell is more important.
100%.
Baby maxing.
I might as well upgrade...
I think I have more mind cores, right?
I'm pretty sure.
Dog!
I'm here to upgrade my mind.
Wait.
Remake Celestial Medicine?
Oh!
It, like...
I can, like, re... Alright.
What do we want, guys?
Guys, what do we want?
Do we want...
HP?
Mana?
Stamina?
Defense?
Or Recovery?
HP and Mana?
Okay...
I can only use once.
HP...
And then...
I hope I did not get one guy.
I literally saw the fastest typer in my chat.
I swear to God.
I...
Whoever typed to me the fastest...
Alright.
I got the HP.
It's time.
Is it time?
Wait, then why the fuck did I go to the Tiger's Cellar?
I didn't even...
Oh, I guess you want me to upgrade my mind thing.
Just walk down?
Oh, I could just walk down.
Oh, yeah!
That's...
That's why.
I could just walk down.
Wait, I didn't know!
I forgot to res... Okay.
We're not going down the slide yet.
I forgot to reset my thing.
We need to reset the baby.
Okay.
Alright.
Baby has been reset.
Wait, I don't even have like...
I don't even have the...
Oh, I have the immunity now.
Okay.
Finally.
We're here.
We're finally here.
I'm back.
We used to be friends.
What happened?
What happened, bro?
We used to be friends!
What happened?
We used to be best of friends!
Wait, did my ability stop?
Wait!
You guys didn't tell me that like...
Wait a minute!
Wait, I didn't know!
When you transform, it's different!
God!
You guys didn't know when you transform, it doesn't exist anymore.
Oh, no!
I didn't know!
I'm so...
I'm so stupid!
Please!
We used to be very good friends!
What happened?
I helped you get that thing!
Oh, God!
Oh!
I wanted to die!
My God!
Okay, we know now!
We know now!
Now we know!
What do you mean I spent three hours to beat this guy?
No!
Don't say that!
Please!
Wait until he starts summoning... He starts summoning tornadoes?
Oh, no!
Okay, we can do this, guys!
Guys, this is...
This is fun!
Now that I know!
I won't use it!
Alright!
Now that we know tornadoes exist...
Surely nothing bad will happen to us!
Right?
Surely!
Alright!
Big baby!
Baby!
Big baby mode!
Baby mode!
You know what?
Hair!
That's fucking right!
Oh, fuck!
Okay!
That's right!
We're all coming in now!
Hair!
Oh, shit!
Let's hope that's not tornadoes, right?
It's not tornadoes, right?
Yeah, that's not tornadoes.
Wait, where did he go?
Where did he go?
Oh, god!
Oh, shit!
Oh!
Okay, we gotta take that potion.
Alright, nice!
Alright, we definitely...
Guys, I think we waste...
We don't use multiple monkeys.
Multiple monkeys is a joke.
Oh, please!
Okay.
Alright.
I don't know what to do.
Gosh.
Nice.
I can get this combo in, right?
Hit attack!
Yes!
I got critical!
That's fucking right!
Stabbed you in the ankle!
You're Achilles heel!
Oh, god!
He has a triumvirate!
What?!
That's right!
We stabbed you in the ankle!
Oh, I don't like that!
I dodged it?
I think I did.
And then stab!
Oh, my god!
He, like, kicked!
Okay.
He brought the bug back!
Dodge!
Come on!
Halfway there!
We're halfway there!
Please!
Stab!
I need a chill!
Okay.
Nice!
Oh, I don't know half of his movesets!
I don't know what I'm doing!
What the fuck?!
Oh, shit!
Okay.
We're fine!
We're okay!
Is this a tornado?!
Oh, is that the tornado?!
Tornado!
Did I do it?
Oh, it is!
I fucking did it!
I fucking knew it!
I saw the wind!
I read the wind!
I have the power of the wind!
Oh, shit!
I'm so sorry!
I am so sorry!
I did not mean that!
You're so cool!
And you're dead!
Oh, shit!
Shit!
Senior guy!
Yeah, why would you want to rule this desert?
I got lost in it for five hours straight!
Six hours!
Huh?!
That's his head?!
Oh my god!
That was his head all along!
Is that the king of Sandland?
Amitabha.
This is...
It's my head!
I lied to you, wasn't it?
You talk about my head now!
It's not his head.
If you're lying,
We did it!
Wait!
So the rat was the bad guy that was all alive!
I'm worthy!
Apparently the rat was the bad guy!
He lied!
I thought we were friends!
I thought we were homies!
Oh, it's stop motion now?
That's so interesting!
Oh my god, it's so...
That's so cute!
I like how...
It's implied that the body was a musician.
He's like, I wanted to be...
I wanted to be a musician!
Dad!
And then the head was like, no.
The body was for music, but the head was for Buddha.
Oh, it was a girl!
Placement!
Oh my god!
The light placement to hide the nipple!
That's...
That's funny!
Whoa!
Oh my gosh, she's Brigante!
Oh shit!
Goodbye, son!
Don't worry.
We raised a good boy.
Hey, what's going on?
No!
What happened to the wife?
Is that the wife?
It was all a dream?
He killed her!
Oh my god!
That's so funny!
It was a dream!
Oh my god.
He killed her!
Oh, my gosh.
Oh my god.
Oh my gosh.
Have you ever looked for the ancient land at the end of the sky?
And have you ever hit a lake, a river, a cliff, or a rock to fight?
I'm afraid that you are confused and confused.
The more you try, the more you can't find it.
A tree and a tiger are the same.
They don't have a destiny, and they don't accept it.
Little monkey, listen to me.
What the wind brings to you is the sound of hope.
Oh gee, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh man, that's sad.
I guess he like got a vision of the future.
It's like...
And then he was like...
He doesn't want to go through that.
Because she basically...
Basically like...
Kills everybody.
And he's like, if I kill her before she kills everybody I love...
It's better that way.
That's so sad.
That's actually so sad.
Oh my god.
That's a sad storyline.
I'm pretty sure it's a vision.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure that's a vision for the future.
And then he was like, yeah, no.
What's this?
Pan gu zhi jin ceng jian feng, bu si zhe feng lai bu shan.
Nei chang feng ba.
Luan le jing gang, jing le luo han.
Wen shu zhou le qing shi, pu xian shi luo han.
Nong de san jie zhen chan.
Ai, zhe ban fa shu gao qiang de nie chu.
Yu jian shi ren de shifu shi tada fu fen.
Que ye cheng le tada zai nan.
Killing Simon's dad.
What about this?
Shou xing qian bai lu, lao jun qi qing niu.
Wen shu zuo qing shi, pu xian yu bai xiang.
Zhe ju chong...
Shuo bu zhun ye shi nei wei de zuo qi.
OK.
Dou shuo yao guai chi ren.
Qi shi ren ye chi ren.
Er qi chi de geng hen.
Na xiao xiao jing di de gong ping jiao yi.
Yu wai mian, yuo yuo he bu tou.
OK.
Yeah, that's the beat.
That's like the artwork of everything that happened, basically.
That's interesting.
Chapter 2, I did not...
I really liked the boss designs.
But oh my god.
Exploring chapter... the map was so difficult.
Like...
Um...
Yeah, it was like...
The chapter was long.
But like...
I think it was long because I kept getting lost.
I kept getting...
Um...
I definitely kept getting lost.
Because everything looked...
Very similar.
And like...
So like...
I just didn't know where to go.
I think like...
I definitely would have got even more lost.
Um...
I would have got more lost.
If like...
You guys didn't help me.
Um...
But I really did like...
I really like...
I really liked the monster designs in chapter 2.
I think I liked the monster designs more in chapter 2 than chapter 1.
The monsters...
The guais I fought in chapter 2 were more interesting.
I think.
And like...
There was more...
The combos were more interesting too.
Um...
I don't think this game needs a map.
It was just because like...
Uh...
Because it was like all similar in area.
Because it was just rocks and sand.
Like...
So it's like...
I couldn't...
It's so hard...
To figure out the landmarks.
Because everything looked so similar.
Because it was not different biomes.
It was like...
Um...
Literally...
Which were the landmarks.
I couldn't figure out what the landmarks were.
Like...
To...
To differentiate.
Uh...
Um...
Like...
Where I was.
But it is...
It was definitely...
I would...
I would think the creature design in chapter 2 was a lot more interesting.
And...
Uh...
Um...
The combos too were...
Were...
It was a lot of different diverse combos and stuff.
I definitely got a lot better.
I think I got a lot better playing this game.
Yeah, I improved a lot.
Alright, let's hit the beginning of chapter 3.
I want to watch the beginning of chapter 3.
White Snow Ice Code.
Is this a snow map?
I miss... I used to be able to...
do Chinese calligraphy.
I used to take classes for it.
I think it's like... I think it's like...
your parents would... my parents would like...
Yeah, my parents would...
take me to like drawing classes.
And in one of them, we would have like Chinese calligraphy.
What?
Another baby?
Baby 3.0.
Oh.
It's the Buddha.
Wait, how did I get here?
Okay.
Alright, get over here.
Okay, no, don't go anywhere.
Not like that.
I said that as a joke.
I didn't think he would actually get over here.
Alright, nice.
Okay, wow.
He actually...
He actually got over here.
I was very surprised.
He did that.
That was a joke.
Wait.
There he is.
There's...
He's just there.
Oh.
Where do I go?
Okay, it's not snow?
I thought this would be a snow area.
Oh, okay.
We go this way.
Alright, we gotta...
He looks older?
No, that's just my costume.
That's just my outfit.
Okay.
We go this way.
Oh, there's the snow.
There it is.
Oh, hey.
There he is too.
Oh sh...
What are you...
Oh my god!
What are you?
Are you also a bat?
Oh my god.
There's multiple bat creatures?
Wait.
What is he?
A scion bat.
Unforced spear in hand.
Clothes and simple guard.
Humble did he stand.
Deep woods.
A world of white.
A perfect hunting in sight.
Oh.
That's another bat.
Oh, it's like...
It's like different regions.
Just bat bat.
It's not mad bat.
He's just regular bat.
Oh.
That's another bat.
He's just...
He's just a regular bat.
He's bat bat.
Where is the incense?
I want to head to an incense area.
Just a bat.
Bat squared.
Oh.
Is that another bat?
Hello bat.
Oh sh...
He slapped me.
No bats can slap me.
Only I slap.
That's right.
Get down.
I'll fly swat you down.
I'm going to get my electric tennis racket.
Bzzz.
I'll grab my electric tennis racket.
I'll zap you.
Snow hill path.
Wait.
There's regular bats.
What the fuck is this Pluto, Pluto goofy scenario?
How did those bats turn into that bat?
Is there a bat here?
Is there a bat hierarchy?
Oh yeah.
You actually have one?
I used to live in Asia.
Yeah.
That's like literally like mandatory.
When you live in Asia you needed an electric tennis racket.
The bat society is literally required.
I like this map.
I already like this map a lot more.
All right.
Let's see.
Let's get the raging sandstorm.
And then do I have enough?
No.
I need more cold iron leaves.
I wonder if I could buy that.
Can I buy cold iron leaves?
Oh, I can craft weapons too.
Oh, 66%.
Okay.
I need to sell.
Uh, store.
Bye.
Uh.
Um.
Oh, there you go.
Okay.
Uh, I need two.
Okay and then I need to sell.
Oh, sell.
The gold reach beads once perched on the roof of a Buddha.
Maybe it can be exchanged for something valuable.
Man.
I'm a I'm a bad monkey.
I grave robbed this beautiful...
Oh, there.
A humble offering to the Buddha.
Anyway, I'm gonna sell it.
I'm a bad monkey.
That's right.
I'm a bad boy.
I need more will.
Okay, we have to farm will later.
It's in a character, honestly.
We're gonna call it here.
That was fun.
I did not expect to stream that long today.
I mean, we're selling...
That's true.
That's true, but you know...
If I was a good monkey, I wouldn't ask for money.
But I'm a bad monkey.
To be fair, Xu Meng is a pretty bad monkey.
He's the bad boy.
But yeah.
That was really fun.
I hope you guys enjoyed.
This was definitely a lot longer playthrough than I expected today.
But I definitely...
I really enjoyed this game.
I definitely enjoyed this game a lot.
I love going through.
I think I might play...
I definitely will play with the Chinese...
The Chinese dub for the future playthrough.
Just because like...
I feel like dialogue-wise...
I think like having English dialogue...
Doesn't really matter as much.
And...
Because the most important plot points...
There is subtitles for it.
But like...
I feel like immersive-wise...
The Chinese dub does feel a lot...
Like immersive.
Like into the story and the...
And...
And I think like the way...
The intonations they speak...
Heavily reminds me of like...
Old classic plays.
Back then.
So like...
It definitely reminds me...
Like those like classic TV shows...
That talks about like...
Like things that happened around this time.
Like it just reminds me...
The acting for it and everything.
I wonder if they got like famous...
Chinese actors and actresses...
For the voice acting.
I wonder.
Because the voice acting is pretty...
Pretty good.
So I'm just like thinking...
Yeah, the Chinese...
Chinese operas.
Yeah, that's what it reminds me of.
Listening to it.
And it definitely feels more immersive.
I feel like...
I do...
I sort of do like the Chinese.
I think it's also because I sort of understand...
What they're saying too.
I mean when they get like super poetic...
When they start going like super poetic...
And classic Chinese literature...
Type of speaking...
I was like...
I don't know what they're saying.
Because I don't...
I don't recognize...
I don't recognize some of the words...
Because it's like old...
Old Chinese dialogue.
I'm just like...
I was like...
But then they were like...
But then they start saying like some...
And then I recognized some of the Chinese...
Chinese.
It's just when it gets super...
Like...
Like old dialect.
I would go like...
Yeah, it's like...
It's like...
Shakespeare English.
But a lot more complicated.
Because they're like new words that I don't know.
It's much harder than Shakespearean English.
And like the way they talk is also very similar to like...
The way...
Like how people would talk in the old...
Like...
At the...
In the old times too.
So it's very...
It's definitely very immersive.
I do enjoy it.
I think as somebody...
As somebody that like...
Grew up with...
Like...
From home and like...
Chinese like...
Literature.
Classic literature and stuff.
It's...
I...
I don't know.
It's just...
It just feels a little more...
Personal?
I guess for me?
So I definitely enjoy it a lot.
But yeah!
I hope you guys had a lot of fun watching.
And...
I definitely enjoyed it a lot.
I can't wait to play on Saturday.
I...
I don't know.
This game is really fun.
It's...
This game...
This game is so fun.
I'm really happy that the review...
Like I'm really happy that the hype was worth it.
Because this game has been like hyped for a long time.
But I was worried that it was like overhyped in a way.
And...
I was incredibly worried that...
You know, when games get overhyped...
It's not...
You get very disappointed.
So...
I am glad that it lived up to its hype.
And that...
For its very first game...
For its very first game?
From the studio?
That's...
This is a really good game for...
The first one they've ever developed.
Like...
I...
Would have never expected...
This to be their very first game.
So...
The studio...
I...
There's like huge expectations on it now.
For any of their future work.
Um...
And...
Honestly...
Like...
Uh...
I'm like just thinking like...
I do hope...
That they don't go...
The route...
Of a lot of...
Especially like...
Western AAA...
Game companies...
Where all they think about is...
Profit...
And releasing games...
Every year.
So I...
I do hope...
That...
Because like...
This game has been in development for...
A very long time.
And a lot of like...
Western AAA companies now...
They're all like...
Release games...
Fast...
And...
Um...
And like...
There's a lot of bugs...
There's a lot of like...
Corn showers...
And everything...
And like...
The game quality...
Obviously...
Dips a lot.
Very similar to movies nowadays.
Like...
If you guys didn't know...
Movies...
Movie franchises...
Currently...
With CGI...
The quality dipped heavily...
Because like...
The CGI department...
Gets like...
Less than...
A few months...
To work on CGI...
For movies...
And then sometimes...
They have to do corrections...
Within a month...
And stuff...
So like...
It's very similar to how like...
Movies themselves...
Are also dipping in quality...
Because they just want to finish the movies...
Fast...
Instead of working on CGI...
For years...
Like...
Back then...
Some CGI would take like...
Years...
To develop...
Um...
And then movies would be in develop...
For a very long time...
But nowadays...
A lot of movies...
Are in develop...
Um...
Are developing...
Like...
Within a year...
Or like...
Within two years...
Which is not...
How it used to be done...
Back then...
And that's why CGI...
Is like...
A lot better...
Versus now...
Sometimes...
Um...
And so like...
I...
I do hope...
That...
After...
This game's success...
That...
The studio...
Will continue...
To take it's time...
Um...
Polishing...
Their games...
And stuff...
Um...
And like...
Uh...
And just like...
Take...
You know...
Like...
It took many years...
For Wukong to be finished...
So I hope...
Like...
In the future...
I don't mind waiting...
If like...
They make games...
Very similar like this...
Um...
And I hope that...
More...
Game companies...
Would also...
Like...
Take their time...
In developing...
Um...
Games...
Like how they used to...
Uh...
Yeah!
Anyway!
It was very fun!
I definitely...
Enjoy it...
So much...
And...
Um...
I can't wait to play it more on Saturday!
Uh...
As always everybody...
Stay hydrated...
Posture check...
Get up and move around...
To get that blood flowing...
And if you stay up for me...
Head to bed!
Cause...
You deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time everybody!
Bye guys!
Bye!
Thank you again for watching everybody!
I'm sorry...
Forgot to say thank you for all the subs...
The subscriptions...
The...
Um...
The gift-a-ships...
Uh...
The...
Super chats...
I really, really do appreciate it guys!
Anyway...
I actually gotta go now...
Bye bye!